So leute da bin ich
Heute werden wir uns mal kotlin angucken oder kotlin oder ich weiß noch nicht mal wie man das überhaupt richtig ausspricht ich glaube es ist kotlin
Not not sicher ja
Aber das heißt auch wir müssen uns wahrscheinlich mit ein bisschen sachen aus java beschäftigen
Da bin ich aber unschlüssig
Ob das nicht ziemlich paints champ wird
Ist von jetbrains ist ja aber es ist ja wohl irgendwie auf
Jvm basis und dementsprechend sind wir auch ziemlich so was die java standard library angeht dran geboten glaube ich
Keine ahnung ich habe ich habe es noch nie großartig verwendet
das ist so
Monka java
was
Microsoft hat auch in java
Das war mir noch gar nicht klar ich kenne nur das oracle java
Beziehungsweise eigentlich ist es ja mittlerweile glaub sogar open jdk ja was ist eigentlich das habe ich nie verstanden leute
Was ist denn der unterschied zwischen open jdk
Und dem oracle java zeug ich dachte ich dachte eigentlich immer das ist das gleiche aber anscheinend ist es doch nicht das gleiche
Und
Was ich auch nicht checke ist was der unterschied zwischen java und java enterprise edition oder sowas ist
Das sind so dinger die habe ich noch nie kapiert also
Fiveheader java kenner können wir das bestimmt erklären
Ach du meinst das ist nur für minecraft na klar das neue minecraft ist doch sogar glaube ich c++
Also dass das neu implementierte minecraft was jetzt nicht 16g ram braucht
Ich habe gehört da bricht doch öfters mal der vulkan aus
Kommerzieller support ja aber ist das feature mäßig irgendwie irgendwie was anderes weil ganz ehrlich wozu brauche ich
kommerziellen support für für die run time im endeffekt ich meine das
Niemand holt sich für dort nett bei microsoft zu wobei ich will das will ich jetzt mal gar nicht so in frage stellen
Vielleicht vielleicht gibt es das ja wirklich vielleicht kann man sich ja für dort netz sogar
Support holen bei microsoft aber ich kenne ich kenne niemand der das bisher gemacht hat
Okay das das ist der erklärung damit kann ich was anfangen
Open jdk war open source nachbauen bis alle oracle gehasst haben dann ist es jetzt offizielle standard okay
Und der standard den macht auch nicht mehr oracle sondern haben die auch so eine art c++
gremium nur für java oder ein jvm gremium oder sowas
Java enterprise hat auch noch mehr features aber wahrscheinlich nichts weltbewegendes oder
Dürfte wahrscheinlich ein bisschen so sein wie
Ich weiß es ist ein dummer vergleich aber ich bringe es trotzdem
Dürfte wahrscheinlich ein bisschen so sein wie ja wie visual studio community versus visual studio professional
Es hat auch ein bisschen mehr features aber die braucht keiner
Soll ich mal kurz package updates haben wir zwar gestern schon aber arch by the way
wer zum teufel
Warum warum nennt man seine library abseil
Abseilen ist für mich ein synonym für ich geh mal kacken
Abseil was ist das github abseil c++
Abseil ich glaube ich glaube das hat nichts mit abseilen zu tun
Augmente standard library
Er hat auch keine erklärung zu dem namen na gut was auch was auch installieren es einfach updaten gut ist
Brauche hier noch mal andere packages updaten
Es gab keine updaten das heißt wir müssen rebooten
Reboot
hat man wieder zeit für mod gehockt der max ist aber immer am start
Der maxi quasi fast jeden stream ist aber ach max ist eigentlich hat es jetzt ich habe es gar nicht mehr im discord geguckt hat
das jetzt alles funktioniert
Mit neuen domains
Wenn wir gerade dabei sind
Das kommt darauf an was man machen will
Läuft okay ich mache mal kurz discord auf ich habe das schon tagelang nicht mehr reingeguckt kurz schauen
Jemand hier rum gespampt hat oder so
Was ist da
Oh nice da bin ich mal gespannt bis ich nachher lese
okay
Ja also wie lange das dauert bis man bis man sich eingearbeitet hat das hängt ganz entscheidend davon ab was du machen willst also
Als erstes musst du dir mal überlegen in welche richtung das gehen soll der einfachste einstieg ist tatsächlich
Du schnappst dir einen browser und einen texteditor und machst ein bisschen javascript um dir das anzugucken
Kannst du dich auch gleich ein bisschen mit html und css auseinandersetzen kannst du webseiten bauen beziehungsweise interaktive webseiten oder halt
Applications wie man das heute nennt weil webseiten alleine klingt ja zu langweilig webapplications kannst du dann bauen
Das schöne ist das hat die mit abstand kleinste einstiegs würde allerdings
Hat es auch eine relativ steile lernkurve sobald man anfängt ein bisschen mehr als vanilla javascript und im text mit dem texteditor machen zu
Wollen dann guckt man sich irgendwelche frameworks an die man lernen muss dann muss man neue javascript features lernen dann muss man
sich eventuell wenn man pech hat je nachdem was man nimmt mit nimmt noch mit webpack auseinandersetzen
Glücklicherweise ist webpack nicht mehr so verbreitet
Irgendwas ist auch bei twitch kaputt vielleicht vielleicht liegt es auch an mir vielleicht streame ich einfach zu oft
in letzter zeit
Man weiß es ja nicht ich meine ich habe aktuell so viele subscriber tatsächlich wie noch nie wir müssen nachher wieder
Subscriber schätzen machen
Gucken ob jemand das gut erraten kann
Zumindest
Was mir aufgefallen ist ich habe sonst immer
War mal im monat so
12 sein so 60 70 damals schwankte so zwischen 50 und 150 oder sowas vielleicht
den follower auf twitch bekommen aber die letzten glaube ich
hier fünf so die letzte woche oder so
Kein mehr doch ich glaube drei oder so
Und
Dabei waren zwei richtige hiq streams dabei die auch die auch zumindest wenn ich mir das hier im chat angeguckt habe richtig gut angekommen sind
Nämlich einmal unser steckdosen flash stream und einmal den
Cloud den den google kubernetes stream sind beide richtig gut angekommen aber twitch
Die milfra steckdose genau aber twitch hat gedacht was natürlich auch sein kann ist
Dass irgendwelche leute follow bottet haben und das jetzt erst mal wieder aufgeräumt wird man weiß ja lieber twitch so genau
dass sich das ungefähr ausgleicht
Dankeschön für den sub
IQ wieder gestiegen
Kannst du erzählt in frankfurt co-location empfehlen nee
also ich kenne
In frankfurt nur standorte wo man sich rex und so zeug mieten kann aber jetzt nicht so nach dem motto
Managt sondern du bekommst halt einen raum und da musst du dann selbst deine sachen einbauen du kriegst quasi netzwerkkabel aus der wand
sozusagen
jetzt
leicht vereinfacht ausgedrückt
Aber so so geschichten mit
Du kannst da deine eigene hardware hosten
Eventuell eventuell darfst du auch selbst rein aber
Du hast auch irgendwelche support sachen kommt kommt wahrscheinlich ein bisschen darauf an was du haben willst ja willst du das komplett
Gemanagt haben dass du auch leute da hinschicken kannst die die festplatte tauschen oder willst du da selbst rein also
Die die einzige sache wo ich das wo ich tatsächlich mal in der location war in frankfurt wo wir uns kein eigenes
Rechenzentrums abteil gemietet haben war im d6 das dürfte aber wahrscheinlich für die meisten leute viel zu teuer nicht erschwinglich und auch nicht
Sinnvoll sein also den zeiten wo ich noch beim provider gearbeitet habe da hatten wir ein ganzes
Im d6 stehen jetzt ich weiß gar nicht gibt es gibt es davon überhaupt ordentliche bilder im internet
Ja ja gut so sehen schränke da drinnen aus d6 von innen ja super sieht man bloß netzwerkschränke
Es sieht auch nicht viel anders aus als in anderen rechenzentren halt gefühlt deutlich mehr netzwerkinfrastruktur
Zumindest dort haben wir den recht gemietet und ich bin mir noch nicht mal sicher ob wir das weg alleine hatten
oder ob wir in diesem recht sogar nur
Paar höhen einheiten gemietet haben das kann nämlich auch sein ich bin mir da nicht mal ganz sicher
Ja und da muss man rein und damals muss man storage neu starten
und ich habe damals auch gesehen wie ein
wie ein
Peering anschluss zwischen providern aussieht das hört man ja öfter so nach dem motto oder das peering
Bei youtube zu youtube von der telekom ist so kacke und hier und da haben sie probleme das ist äußerst unspektakulär
Wie so ein peering aussieht als das peering oder heißt es peering peering glaube ich
Das ist letztendlich ein stecker also das ist ein kabel was du in deinen switch schräg schräg router stöpselst
Und auf der anderen seite stöpselst du das in einen switch schräg schräg router
Von einem anderen provider fertig mehr ist das nicht natürlich kann man das beliebig aufblähen
Aber ich habe damals unser peering mit free net gesehen das war stinknormales kabel
Könnte könnte glasfaserkabel gewesen sein aber
Von unserem switch an den switch fertig der router switch schräg schräg router
Das war das gesamte peering
Was jetzt das blicke ich jetzt nicht was willst du wie jetzt
Ach so was du programmieren willst habe nämlich ein problem mit meiner tastatur ich will halt mit einer software oder im code
Der tastatur gucken warum einige tasten plötzlich doppelt gehen oder teilweise gar nicht das nervig
Das wirst du dir aber wohl kaum in der mit der software angucken können das wird mechanisch bedingt oder im
ungünstigsten fall
Direkt in dem controller von der tastatur passieren das wirst du nicht einfach auslesen können
Haupt also das eigentliche problem wird höchstwahrscheinlich mechanisch bedingt sein also gerade
mechanische also
clicky clicky
tastaturen mechanische tastaturen die neigen dazu zu wie nennt man das
Doppelte tastenanschläge zu haben wir haben die heißen das so prellen oder so was also ich hatte ich hatte auch schon
mechanische tastaturen wenn du da auf den knopf also wenn du dir wirklich zu fest
auf den auf die taste
Gedrückt hast dann kamen doppelte tastenanschläge und es war mega nervig
Und die ganz ehrlich die schlechteste tastatur die aber bei weitem nicht die billigste war die schlechteste tastatur die ich je hatte
War die hier korsar
k95 rgb
Die ist abfakt teuer gewesen weil wahrscheinlich weil rgb
Und ganz ganz ganz im ernst ich mach das ding mal groß
Vielleicht hatte ich auch ein sonntagsmodell also wenn ihr die tastatur habt und damit zufrieden seid ist das schön für euch
Aber ich habe mir in der tastatur so viele probleme gehabt also erstens hatte ich doppelte tastenanschläge
Ich weiß nicht mal was es war ich glaube dass es
Ich habe mich doch im stream immer drüber aufgeregt was war denn das backspace
Nee
V
Kontroll v war es es war v genau ich habe ich habe ich habe manchmal doppelt doppelt copy pasted und so was
das war extrem nervig
du
Ich habe kontroll v gedrückt hat auf einmal so gemacht
Also hier ich habe das copy pasted habe eingefügt auf einmal hatte ich das irgendwie so hatte ich das irgendwie zwei dreimal drinstehen ganz ganz schrecklich
Also das das war wirklich das war wirklich mist
der grund warum ich mir das ding für daheim geholt habe ist war tatsächlich die die makrotasten und die
programmierfähigkeiten aus und vielleicht ein bisschen rgb von den features her also auch auch hier vorne mit dem mit dem
Mit der handballenauflage wobei die auch nicht nicht richtig richtig gut war die war sehr gummimäßig weniger weich aber das war okay
So also dass das war eines der großen probleme in der statur hatte
dass ich doppelte tastenanschläge hatten mit v jetzt habe ich da habe ich mehrfach mehrfach
da
so
Dann
Hatte ich das problem dass manche tasten nicht mehr richtig funktioniert haben
Wann es war glaube ich umschalten war glaube ich irgendwelche numm tasten hier oben das weiß ich noch als ich mit i3 hier
Desktop umschalten wollte ging es manchmal nicht da muss ich mehrfach die gleiche taste drücken
Danach hatte ich übrigens eine logitech mit der war es auch nicht viel besser da ist mir eine taste abgebrochen abgebrochen
Ich weiß auch nicht was mit modernen tastaturen hochpreisigen modernen tastaturen los ist dass sie so probleme haben
So also die zwei sachen hatte ich und ganz ehrlich ich hatte das ding nicht lange
ich hatte das
eineinhalb jahre oder sowas
Und da hat es schon angefangen kaputt zu gehen
Richtig richtig räudig so und das nächste ding dass es jetzt allerdings also das waren zwei wirklich
Kann man sagen da geht es jetzt nicht um
Subjektive ein oder zwei objektive fehler an der tastatur so dann hatte ich aber auch noch ein paar subjektive sachen die mir persönlich überhaupt nicht
gefallen haben erstens hatte ich den eindruck ich kann es nicht genau beschreiben warum und zwar waren die tastatur waren die
die oberfläche von den tasten war zu
Glatt
Komisch zu beschreiben
Aber ich hatte nicht richtig halt auf den tasten
Ich meine ja alle tastaturen sind oben glatt aber ihr hattet sicher ihr hattet doch auch schon mal unterschiedlich tastaturen in den händen du hast du hast
tasten die sind und
Die sind die alles ein bisschen gebogen oben aber du hast teilweise tasten wenn du damit den finger so ein bisschen drüber
Drüber streichste du merkst da schon dass du minimalen widerstand hattest hast so dass wenn du die
Beim angenommen du legst die finger ordentlich auf wasd dann bleiben die finger da halt drauf wenn du die nicht wenn du nicht absichtlich
Hin und her wackelst
Hatte ich hier überhaupt nicht war ganz nervig war ganz ganz schwammiges gefühl ich hatte nie den eindruck
Und ich habe auch das hatte ich auch noch bei keiner anderen tastatur ich hatte auch das
Nicht das gefühl dass ich mit den fingern auf den richtigen tasten bin
Also ganz im ernst wenn ich auf der tastatur nicht drauf gucke und nicht sicher feststellen kann
Ob ich auf wasd gelandet bin
Ohne auf die tastatur gucken zu müssen
Dann stimmt irgendwas nicht
Mein wasd an sich ist ja recht einfach festzustellen du musst gucken ob das f daneben hast aber trotzdem
Du willst es du willst es eigentlich wissen und ich glaube das lag daran
dass du zwischen caps lock
Nicht nicht so richtig in abstand hattest und zwischen tap also mit der mit der aktuellen tastatur die ich hier habe habe ich halt
So die tasten habe ich merkt es sofort ich merke instant wenn ich hier meine finger richtig auf wasd liegen
Habten so und die rutschen dann auch nicht rum also damit hatte ich damit habe ich ein problem es hat mir überhaupt nicht gefallen
Und ne ne macht ja macht ja nichts raus ich das muss man muss man mal erzählen falls die leute sich das kaufen wollen
Und ein ding womit ich überhaupt gar nicht klar gekommen bin
Was hast du aktuell für das ich habe ich habe mehrere ich kann ich sag dir gleich was ich für was verwenden verwende
Also ein problem wo ich gar nicht drauf klar gekommen bin bis zum schluss nicht auf gar nicht drauf klar gekommen bin ist
Übrigens diese geriffelte lehrt hast da habe ich bis heute nicht verstanden warum die geriffelt ist jetzt lieber war wir es die riffeln sollen
Zumindest eine sache auf die ich überhaupt nicht
Echt war nie da dabei geriffelte wasd ist okay möglich möglich
Möglich möglich
Da hätte ich vielleicht mal in die packung gucken müssen also dann kann man den kritikpunkt schon mal streichen aber der rest bleibt bestehen und
Bei den anderen tasten war es ja im prinzip genau das gleiche
So aber eine sache wo ich bis bis zum schluss nicht auf klar gekommen bin ich war chat ihr könnt mir mal sagen wie ihr das
macht aber ich
Stelle öfters mal ganz gerne fest dass meine tastatur richtig liegt und alles auch ohne dass ich
Also ich überhaupt nicht ich sage ich überprüfe ganz gerne mal meine tastatur und so und alles richtig liegt
Ohne dass ich drauf gucken will und wie ich das mache ist folgendes ich gehe mit dem kleinen finger an den linken unteren
Rand der tastatur und ich weiß der linke untere rand der tastatur ist kontroll
und das ist hier nicht so
Ich bin regelmäßig mit meinem finger
Zwischen den makro tasten und kontroll stecken geblieben mit dem kleinen finger beim beim fühlen ob ich die tastatur an der seite habe
Und ich habe oftmals
G6 anstatt kontroll gedrückt weil ich gesagt habe ok tastatur und links das muss kontroll sein
Mag irgendwie ein bisschen übungssache sein war aber war aber total
unintuitiv
Hat mich hat mich gestört ja und dementsprechend kann ich sagen die tastatur kann ich zumindest nicht empfehlen
Ja die die untere makro taste hatte ich auch gar nicht gar nicht belegt
Aus aus dem grund die makro fähigkeiten sonst was war
Okay, würde ich mal sagen nicht super nice aber okay
So aktuell habe ich folgendes ich habe zwei ich habe zwei tastaturen ich habe einmal eine
Ducky one was ich witzig finde weil es auch schon ein paar leute im chat vorgeschlagen haben hier
Einfach max ans trinken hat man gleich
Exzellent mach ich jetzt mal
Also irgendwelche leute haben geschrieben ich soll mir eine ducky tastatur kaufen genau
so
Ich habe auch eine ducky one skyline aber die alte und full size
Also sowas hier mit num block
Allerdings mit dem nicht mit diesem hässlichen enter key sondern mit dem normalen
die so so sieht die aus
Wobei ich mir auch ein bild ich habe die auch mit einem blauen enter key komisch vielleicht kommt man in tauschen oder so wirklich
Also sowas hier in der kombination die habe ich am start die habe ich allerdings auf der arbeit mittlerweile
Was heißt mittlerweile mittlerweile ist gut gesagt ich habe mir die explizit für die arbeit gekauft damals und ich habe die dann auch mit
Die alte firma genommen habt jetzt in der neuen firma auch
Ich habe quasi das einzige was ich mitgenommen habe von der alten in der neuen für die neue firma ist meine tastatur und meine maus
Maus habe ich noch eine
Logitech
Logitech g502 pro toyscore
Also das ding habe ich am start auf der arbeit als tastatur und das mega nice tippt sich wirklich sehr angenehm
Das einzige problem ist das ist eine rein mechanische tastatur das heißt du nervst ein bisschen die leute auf der arbeit
Wenn man nicht jetzt total heftig drauf schlägt dann geht das aber
Es gibt allerdings auch silikon ringe für die tastaturen
Das
Macht es bei manchen tasten ein bisschen erträglicher so und für daheim habe ich eine logitech g512
so eine
Sowas hier das ist nicht die geilste tastatur die ich jemals hatte aber
Ich habe schon die zweite weil die erste kaputt gegangen ist
Ich habe ich habe auch übelst glück mit meiner tastatur hardware gehabt die letzten jahre aber man muss sagen logitech hat das ding einfach ausgetauscht
beziehungsweise amazon hat das ding einfach ausgetauscht also die ist die war kaputt
und dort ist mir tatsächlich
control abgebrochen
Die kontrolltaste ist abgebrochen
Ich hätte nicht gedacht dass das überhaupt passieren kann aber kontrolle ist abgebrochen
Und ich also ich kann mir vorstellen warum die abgebrochen ist aber die darf nicht abbrechen und zwar die ist abgebrochen weil wenn meine tastatur
Schief liegt dann greife ich hier unten links an die tastatur also da habe ich dann
Da habe ich mein mittelfinger an an dem gehäuse und meinen zeigefinger habe ich an der kontrolltaste und dann schiebe ich halt die tastatur
Ein bisschen wieder in die richtung wie sie hingehört
Und das hat die kontrolltaste einfach nicht verkraftet die ist kaputt gegangen
Die ist verreckt komplett
Und wenn das abbricht kannst du die halt auch nicht fixen
Das ist ja keine rubberdome tastatur oder sowas wo du auseinanderschraubst was im dreck raus pustest und gut ist wenn der schalter im arsch ist
Ist es ist das ding halt kaputt
Also da war der war sowohl der schalter im arsch als auch die kontrolltaste selbst gehen also
Ich weiß ich hatte übelst pech mit mit meinen mein tastaturen das letzte mal aber muss man echt sagen logisch hat das ding
Ausgetauscht ohne probleme zack habe ich eine neue tastatur gekriegt hat wunderbar funktioniert und die neue hält
Also anscheinend hat sie hat sie ein bisschen morsche kontrolltaste gehabt
Logitech g hub das ding habe ich auch am start auch wenn es doch hier ist es ja finde ich auch nicht so geil
Aber gibt gibt schlimmere software
Ich muss noch was zur ducky
tastatur sagen
Weil eines der gründe schlechthin warum ich mir die gekauft habe für die arbeit war
Dass die keine zumindest dachte ich das zum damaligen zeitpunkt so dass die keine irgendwie großartige software sonst irgendwas braucht
Und ich wollte nichts mehr für makros und sonst was also der unterschied also muss ja also der grund warum ich daheim die hab
und
eine ducky one
Auf der arbeit beziehungsweise die zwei unterschied tastaturen warum ich nicht zweimal eine ducky one habe ist
dass ich daheim gerne was hat mit makros und auf der arbeit will ich nichts mit makros haben
Weil das ist unterliegungs mit custom software für tastaturen und so eh so ein ding
Bis ich irgendwann festgestellt habe das wollte ich jetzt mal hier lobend lobend erwähnen dass die ducky one
Tatsächlich makro funktionalität hat ohne software die tastatur hat anscheinend ein microcontroller drin
Mit der man makros mit dem man makros programmieren kann
Ja custom treiber sind immer so ein bisschen problematisch weil
Je nachdem wie die software funktioniert wenn die auf betriebssystemebene erst funktioniert dann funktionieren einige sachen nicht zum beispiel
Wenn ich in vm war bin und du willst jetzt mit nehmen wir mal auto hotkey nehmen wir auto hotkey auto hotkey ist so mit das
bekannteste was es so gibt für für
Tastatur input faken wenn ich hier in vm war drinne bin und vm hat meine maus geklebt
Und ich hätte habe jetzt ein auto hotkey laufen im hintergrund unter windows was sagen wir mal
Rausgehen möchte aus der vm dann geht das nicht weil vm war workstation so low level meine tastatur
Da funktioniert auto hotkey nicht du kannst keine richtigen usb kommandos senden mit auto hotkey sondern du kannst halt nur
Windows quasi sagen hier ist wohl eine tastatur gedrückt deswegen wenn man wenn man wirklich low level makros braucht für automatisierung zum beispiel
switch aus einer vm raus und sowas dann geht das mit manchen sachen nicht das hier keine ahnung ob wie gut das
Das ist aber wenn es eine firmware ist dann ist es höchstwahrscheinlich so dass es tatsächlich direkt von der tastatur ausgeht und dann ist gut
So das war zumindest der grund warum ich daheim logische tastatur habe und auf der arbeit hatte ducky one skyline
aber
Was mir erst im nachhinein aufgefallen ist
Die ducky one skyline hat ein microcontroller drin mit der man doch makros programmieren kann ich zeige euch mal
Back gibt sie irgendwie von hinten
Bild von hinten guck mal die hat hier unten nämlich so eine so einen switch man sieht das gar nicht
Ducky one skyline manual ich zeige euch das mal haben die hier
ein offizielles pdf
Download
User manual
Jawohl
China chinesen ding
Ach guck mal es gibt ja sogar ducky macro das kann ich noch gar nicht das gab es damals noch nicht und weiß ich ob das meine
Tastatur unterstützt nice sehr schön
zumindest meine die erste ducky one skyline die hatte da unten so eine geschichte zum
Mit so dip switchen zum makro programmieren da musstest du die tastatur umdrehen den
Makro das micro button anmachen da konntest du was drücken und da konntest du den makro button wieder ausmachen so das war sehr sehr
Umständlich ist es damit makros aufzuzeichnen aber das coole ist die befehle kommen dann halt auch direkt von der tastatur und sind da halt mit
drinnen on board also
Eigentlich gar nicht übel
So viel zum thema tastatur
Nämlich lange zu ausgelassen
Nee quatsch die habe ich komplett selbst bezahlt die tastatur die kenne ich nicht
Das ist nicht die ergonomische tastatur oder
Also leute die ich glaube die tastatur die ich am längsten in benutzung hatte
Damals wo es obwohl ich noch kein geld verdient habe und ich wirklich gucken musste wie ich wie ich über die runden komme so
Taschengeld mäßig habe ich auch nicht viel gekriegt als die tastatur die ich am längsten verwendet haben war ein microsoft office
Keyboard
Das da
Kennt das noch jemand hatte das zufällig auch jemand rar ist die rare
Das ding hatte ich ewig
Was das das ist also aus zeiten wo tastaturen versucht wurden super ergonomisch zu machen
Das ding hatte ich ewig das hatte ich das war
release date
Release date das war was für sich 1998 oder so war das wann das rausgekommen ist
Wir suchen wir suchen nicht nach release date sondern review
Das war wie so ein altes nokia handy man findet das noch mal hier pc welt oder irgendwelche schrottzeiten haben doch bestimmt sowas
Und man findet das geil wobei da stand doch da stand doch wie heißt das ding
rt 9 4 5 0
Release date
Das findet man auch nicht mal
fest
chip
Welche seiten von damals müssen den kram noch getestet haben
War so immer das hatte ich das habe ich ewig gehabt dass das das hatte ich wirklich eben ihr müsst davon ausgehen ich hatte
das so lang ich habe damit noch
Cs gespielt bevor es 16 wurde ich habe damit noch cs 05 und sowas gespielt mit dem mit der taste so alt ist die ist
die ist die tastatur also vielleicht nicht so release aber aber kurz danach und
zeitgleich hatte ich noch eine microsoft
Intelli mouse
Explorer
Nicht die nicht die die erste die allererste ja
Die da nee ja aber in anderer farbe hatte ich die
aber nee nee nee nee nee nee nee das war das war nicht die die sie die sah der aber
So sah meine aus genauso exakt so
Und
Das war eine der ersten optischen
ob optikel explorer ist das ding
Ja ja
Und damals waren optische mäuse noch richtig schrott
Aber aber wie gesagt dass microsoft also die microsoft das microsoft office keyboard das hatte ich so lang das hatte ich bestimmt über zehn
jahre dieses teil
Das habe ich glaube ich erst weggeschmissen
Nachdem ich also ich kann es ich kann es mir ungefähr zusammenreihe zusammen reimen
Weil es gab ja mal eine zeit da habe ich viel pc gespielt und dann gab es eine zeit dann habe ich
Total viel xbox 360 gespielt es war dann wahrscheinlich so 2005 rum
Oder so xbox 36 ja genau irgendwie 2006 rum bis bis
2011 12 wo ich dann auch die
Call-of-Duty zeug im fabian und so gespielt habe so viel xbox gespielt und als ich danach wieder angefangen habe wieder viel mehr pc
Zu spielen da habe ich die rausgeschmissen so als eine der ersten abends handlung also ich hatte das ding quasi
10 bis 15 jahre diese tastatur
Ich glaube das wäre mit der aktuellen tastatur gar nicht machbar wenn da schon nach einem jahr die kontrolltaste abbricht
Na gut lange nur über tastaturen jetzt gelabert gucken wir uns mal jetzt was das eigentliche an was im titel steht
Aliexpress tastatur das auch mutig
Ja so ist das halt chat gab es schon mal einen stream wo wir die ersten 45 minuten irgendwas sinnvolles gemacht haben
So habe ich die taste habe ich habe ich die poemme neu gestartet
Ich glaube ich glaube schon
Chat ja doch doch doch ich glaube
Egal ich dachte doch ich glaube ich habe neu gestartet ich starte die noch mal neu
Wieder mal c++ nicht immer bloß auf
Fernseht vermeiden lässt gibt es hier nichts c++
übrigens seitdem ich das so eingestellt habe dass ich
Einfach nur noch start x eintippen muss ich frage mich warum gibt es leute die noch display manager und sowas verwenden
Einfach auf der kommandozeile einloggen ein kommando ausführen und das
Der desktop startet wozu braucht man display manager mit irgendwelchen fancy login
alles blutet leute
blutet
arts by the way nicht blutet
By the way i use arts by the way
gut
Vermutlich aber wir updaten den ganzen klempel mal gibt neue rider version pie charm professional
Aus welchem grund habe ich pie charm professional installiert es ist jetzt nicht so als würde ich so viel python zeug machen
Ach doch ich weiß wofür wir das installiert haben hier für das für das plugin hier oben
Für den für das timer plugin was wir gebaut haben das haben wir ja in python gemacht
Und natürlich haben wir dann auch gleich pie charm professional installiert so als professional hecker man
Professional kann ich installieren weil
Ich habe irgendwann mal so ein old desktop pack von jetbrains geholt
Dementsprechend kann ich jetzt auch pass mal auf ich kann nicht einfach nur intelligent community edition installieren ich kann sogar
intelligent
ultimate installieren
Was ist eigentlich der unterschied dazwischen
Ultimate versus community gucken wir als haben wir uns schon mal angeguckt
Aber ich habe schon wieder vergessen
Okay package updates im hintergrund sind ein wenig laggy kotlin geht in beiden
ultimate
kann auch
ruby
ultimate
rust
Eigentlich brauche ich das nicht
Übrigens chat wir müssen demnächst wieder ein bisschen frontendentwicklung machen und zwar ich habe mich jetzt ich habe mich jetzt endgültig dazu entschieden
Ich werde den fiat champ etwas überarbeiten
Alter wie viele wie viele comments hat das bitteschön
Was irgendjemand offert mir 50 dollar wait a minute was ist da los das habe ich gar nicht gelesen
get rude
Oh shit was hier los
Das ist richtig ich habe es nie mit dem alfa romeo getestet
Oh okay
Ja also was ich jetzt weil ich jetzt sagen wollte
Ich habe mich jetzt dazu entschieden ich werde das ding mal überarbeiten weil ich höchstwahrscheinlich selbst demnächst probleme mit der app
Also ist eines der gründe und es so viele coole sachen gibt immer noch einbauen können könnte und einbauen kann die auch wirklich was bringen
Und man das grundsätzlich auch mal ein bisschen überarbeiten muss aus den aus den sachen die ich jetzt gelernt habe
Und eines der eines der wünsche die user immer geäußert haben ist
Sie wollen das auch stand alone benutzen können eigentlich rewrite in russland
Die wollen das auch stand alone benutzen können und da habe ich mir überlegt ich mache folgendes
Nachdem ich probleme habe wenn ich das einbauen möchte dass es mehrere autos
Gleichzeitig von mehreren herstellern unterstützt weil aktuell unterstützt die app zwar
Fiat jeep dodge
Ram truck dinger und und alfa romeo und so theoretisch zumindest
Ist das problem ist das problem dass man die app nicht einbauen kann
Theoretisch zumindest
Ist das problem wenn du zwei accounts hinzufügen willst weil du autos von zwei unterschiedlichen hersteller zum beispiel irgend so ein ami
Herkommt und sagt hey er hat so einen fetten ram truck und noch einen kleinen fiat dann geht das nicht zusammen und du kannst du
Kannst du das addon nicht doppelt installieren du kannst zwar mehrere autos bei fiat haben aber du kannst nicht zwei autos hier gleichzeitig haben das
Ist eigentlich bescheuerte limitierung die daran liegt dass ich ursprünglich daran gedacht habe dass es ja
Möglich sein kann dass jemanden fiat und jeep hat zum beispiel und das mit der gleichen app machen wird
Es gibt ein paar sachen die man da grundlegend umbauen muss und die konfiguration über home assistant funktioniert auch nicht richtig
in dem fall
Deswegen habe ich mir überlegt wir bauen einfach ein kleines webinterface zum konfigurieren ein
Nein, wir rewriten das nicht in rast leute wie kommen wir darauf warum
Wenn ich nie fertig werden will dann würde ich das in rast rewriten
blazer
Welt
Einfach mal ein spontaner rast rewrite
Chat wir rewriten das nicht in rast
Da können die krustentiere hier noch so viel schreiben
Oder das frontend in rast webassembly ja klar weil ich das auch komplett
Unmaintainable für mich machen will das webfrontend
Warum warum nicht gleich warum nicht gleich das frontend in .NET MAUI in webassembly übersetzt und über
Websockets angebunden oder war irgendwie ganz abgedreht das zeug. Die rewriten das gar nicht
Ich werde von mod gesabotiert guckt euch das an
Wuppdi dankeschön für den sub
Chat es ist vollkommen egal wie oft ihr abstimmt rewrite in rast
Ich werde es im leben nicht in rast rewriten
Ich finde das auch gut wenn ihr das rewritet ich rewrite es nämlich nicht
Ihr könnt rewriten was ihr lustig seid
Rewrite in Haskell natürlich das kommt als nächstes
Mod mod mod giz
Können ja auch wir können eine umfrage umfrage machen rewrite in kobol
Wobei ich gehe mal davon aus selbst wenn ich das wirklich machen möchte ich glaube mit kobol wäre es gar nicht wirklich
krass champ
hört mal bloß auf
Meinung zu nehmen habe ich noch nie benutzt
Ja und da bauen wir dann webfrontend zum konfigurieren dann kann man das nämlich stand alone verwenden und auch so besser konfigurieren gut
Aber erste 45 minuten um jetzt können wir mal zur eigentlichen sache des streams kommen
Wisst ihr was ich installiere einfach nur die community was zu was hier los mit der oberfläche
Habt ihr es gerade gesehen
Auch kommt mal das ding kackt voll ab wenn man über den install button geht
Aber auch nur wenn man eine weile drauf bleibt wenn man schnell drüber geht nicht
so let's go
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen ich habe absolut gar keine ahnung von kotlin nein habe ich nicht war die jetzt
Das das muss ich mir das muss ich mir aufhören ich muss mir später angucken oder vielleicht können wir es auch noch
Vielleicht können wir es auch noch im stream gucken
Mal schauen mal google
Die community edition ist für geringverdiener
Du meinst du meinst ich muss jetzt ich muss jetzt den den
Aus dem weg geringverdiener move machen und und die wieder an installen
Ultimate okay
Ihr müsst einfach in meine gruppe kommen leute dann könnt ihr euch auch professionelle ideas leisten
So lasst mal was wenn man anfangen will
Sachen zu automatisieren von zum beispiel in sachen in vm plus eine anderen software software verteilung software
Was benutzt man dann am besten
Schwarz 33 ich habe keine ahnung was du meinst
Was genau willst du automatisieren
Ich werde echt nicht schlau draus wahrscheinlich kann ich dir sogar was zu raten aber erst mal muss ich verstehen was du machen willst
Aktuell bin ich eher so im
Dem modus ich verstehe es nicht
Es gibt sehr viele sachen um andere sachen zu automatisieren aber es die fragen welche sachen gemeint sind
So ultimate edition installiert jetzt ist alles gut
intelligent
ultimate
Potential zeug das wäre eine möglichkeit aber es kommt darauf an was für sachen es sind wenn du das unter windows automatisieren willst
Ich meine ich sage nicht dass es nicht geht mit ansonnenpuppet schön ist es auf jeden fall nicht aber willst du irgendwelche ui sachen oder browser
Webseiten oder so automatisieren dann ist das schon mal komplett falschen tools dafür
Das erinnert mich an einen punkt früher
Noch während meiner ausbildung
Oder was heißt noch eigentlich hauptsächlich während meiner ausbildung da wurden die azubis immer verdonnert bei dailies protokollen zu schreiben
Ja das war die zeit wo man auch schon angefangen hat versucht versucht agil zu sein aber dann so
Agilitätskiller gemacht wie protokolle fürs daily schreiben richtig hängen geblieben und die azubis mussten immer protokolle fürs daily schreiben damals und ich war
Damals auch azubi also musste ich öfters protokoll fürs daily schreiben
Und wir hatten einen im team damals der hatte nie bock darauf im daily ordentlich was zu erzählen
Aus meiner sicht heute vollkommen verständlich heute wäre ich wahrscheinlich derjenige gewesen
Der auf diesen kram keinen bock hätte und immer wenn der gefragt wurde was hast du gemacht dann hat er gesagt dinge
Und wenn man ihn dann weiter gefragt hat ja erzähle mal ein bisschen konkret hat gesagt sachen
Und danach hat er gesagt zeug
Du hast aus dem nicht rausgeklickt was er gemacht hat und was er machen will
und irgendwann und jetzt
Story aus meiner azubi zeit ja und irgendwann habe ich mir gedacht weißt du was
Wenn der kerl einfach zu 90 prozent nur das so erzählt schreibst du es einfach ins protokoll rein
Und dann habe ich bei dem ein paar tage lang ins protokoll reingeschrieben
hat gemacht sachen
Und irgendwann hatte ich doch tatsächlich hat irgendjemand dieses protokoll gelesen
Es anscheinend haben da wirklich unsere damaligen chefs sogar die protokolle
überwacht und reingeguckt und irgendwann habe ich dann eine doofe nachricht bekommen über
Kennt das noch jemand hatte hatte jemand mal die ehre damit
Ich frage nur ob jemand die pains champigkeit dieser software kennt habe ich die nachricht bekommen über den lotus notes chat
Übrigens wer ist eigentlich auf die dumme idee gekommen die personalabteilung human resources umzubenennen
Es ist ja schön und gut dass arbeitgeber das so sehen und wenn ich arbeitgeber wäre würde ich es wahrscheinlich auch so sehen aber ich
Finde diesen namen einfach nur maximal unglücklich
so zumindest
habe ich eine nachricht bekommen über über lotus notes same time
warum in dem protokoll nichts ordentliches drin steht für den da habe ich ihm halt gesagt
damals habe ich gesagt ja gut
Ich frage den jedes mal was er macht und der antwortet immer nur mit sachen
Habe gemeint ja aber das können wir da nicht reinschreiben weil das würden ja alle sehen
Aber der kann ich doch nichts machen er sagt halt nix ich kann ihm ja schlecht jetzt
Irgendwie sagen ich werfe dich aus dem fenster
Was soll ich machen wenn er einfach nicht sagen will auf dreimal nachfragen
Da hatte die andere seite auch keine so wirkliche antwort drauf hat er nur zu mir gesagt so nach dem motto ja guckt doch beim nächsten
protokoll dass wenn er was anderes reinschreibt
Und das habe ich dem dann erzählt demjenigen der das der hier immer sachen und dinge gesagt hat und daraufhin hat er gesorgt auch
Ich hatte keinen bock mehr auf den laden ich soll weiterhin sachen rein schreiben habe ich weiter sachen reingeschrieben und danach hat sich nie wieder
Einer beschwert man würde eigentlich davon ausgehen dass sie sich die protokolle besonders konkret angucken
Wenn du schon angerufen würdest dazu
Wir haben dann einfach weiterhin sachen reingeschrieben
Es kann natürlich auch sein dass sie sich wirklich dann bei ihm gemeldet haben und nicht mehr bei mir weil ich meine ich war
Azubi und protokollschreiber
Was soll ich da dran ändern wenn der typ ja nix sagt ja
Sachen machen sind immer effizient
Ach hier okay sorry für die undeutlichkeit dem macht nichts muss das ist nicht schlimm sage ich meinen azubis auch immer das ist nicht wild
Wenn er wenn wenn wenn man es nicht versteht wichtig ist nur das was auf nachfrage hinwegs mal gescheit erklären kann dann das ganze
Klar stellt er kann erwartet keiner dass man von anfang an alle perfekte sachen für alles die die passenden wörter und buzzwords kennt
Bei the way ihr wisst ja cloud anbieter sind keine cloud anbieter mehr sondern hyperscaler also wenn ihr cool sein wollt sagt ihr demnächst
So noch hyperscaler sorry für die undeutlichkeit also zum beispiel neue vm snapshots erstellen und gleichzeitig updates von software draufladen
bisher muss man das ganze von hat man ach so ja
Das würde ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so sehr auf vm ebene sehen sondern eine vm ist ja ein virtuell
Virtualisiertes system ob das system da drin jetzt virtualisiert ist oder auf echte hardware läuft ist es ist dem system ja innen drin
Relativ egal also das heißt wenn du dich um paket updates und so kümmern willst
Dann muss das in dem system in drinnen passieren das hat ja nichts mit einer vm lösung zu tun
snapshots erstellen das sieht schon wieder anders aus
snapshots erstellen wenn du vm verwendest und in kombination also esx und
Wie heißt das ganze zeug wie es vier und was es nicht alles gibt da gibt es garantiert lösungen damit kenne ich mich aber nicht
Aus weil ich das nie administrieren musste und auch nie bock drauf hatte wie man automatisch snapshots und backups von vm erstellt gibt es garantiert
Ich kenne ich kenne vm zum beispiel aber ich gehe davon aus dass so sachen wie
Automatisierte snapshots per skript und sowas easy möglich sind mit wie es vier out of the box
Chat gibt ihr wisst vielleicht besser vielleicht jemand von euch vm wer atmen am start oder jemand der das schon gemacht hat
software
Updates da musst du dich vom betriebssystem seite aus drum kümmern da hat die vm ja nichts mitzutun
Ich meine vm wer kann ja schlecht wissen wie du betriebssystem updates machst für alle
150 verschiedene betriebssysteme die du theoretisch in der vm laufen lassen könntest du könntest am mac drinnen laufen haben
Ja, könntest macht kaum einer
linux windows oder meinetwegen dos ja woher soll deine vm wissen deine virtualisierung software
Wie du in den jeweiligen betriebssystemen gescheit updates machst das heißt du brauchst zwei sachen du brauchst einmal eine backup backup
Snapshot lösung oder halt einfach nur ein paar kronen skripts für vm wer sowas geht garantiert vm wer
Out of the box für automatische snapshots erstellen gucke aber dass deine snapshots ordentlich rotiert sonst wird
Ratzfatz ziemlich viel gigabyte verbraten und hier brauchst du irgendwas für das jeweilige betriebssystem was du abdecken willst zum beispiel
Wenn du viele linux betriebssysteme hast dann bietet sich sowas wie ansible an
Oder auch puppet oder chef oder salt stack aber ich persönlich würde sagen ansible
Du kannst aber auch wenn es nur betriebssystem updates sind andere lösungen verwenden kannst zum beispiel
Wenn du nicht viele kisten hast kannst du den skript bauen was sich ein lock psh und update macht wobei ich das tatsächlich dann
Ansible vorziehen würde du kannst auch gucken dass du deine systeme wenn sie alle rettet sind in sowas wie satellite reinsteckt oder
spacewalk hieß das früher
rettet
spacewalk
Ist das noch spacewalk has been discontinued
Heute nennt sich noch satellite
Wir hatten mal bei uns
Jemand der der dokumentation geschrieben hat und der konnte das wort spacewalk das wort spacewalk nicht aussprechen
Der hat immer gesagt spacewalk
Da kann ich mich heute noch dran erinnern wir haben immer richtig gequatscht es ist jetzt ja nicht so als hätte ich die geilste
Englisch aussprache überhaupt aber ich war es ernsthaft spacewalk
anstatt spacewalk
Der Typ war geil, der hat es auch immer so geil ausgesprochen der spacewalk
Mittlerweile nach einer weile hieß das bei uns umgangssprachlich auch bei allen leuten spacewalk
Ein bisschen so wie manche leute
Gyra besonders geil aussprechen müssen wir haben dazu immer noch am ende immer noch spacewalk gesagt
Spacewalk
Gut also du brauchst irgendeine software halt für deinem betriebssystem zu managen und bei der gelegenheit wenn du sowas wie ansible verwendest
bietet sich vielleicht auch an
Die sachen die du customized hast an einem linux also sprich welche packages du installiert hast verzeichnisse eingelegt
Dienste gestartet und gestoppt und sowas das vielleicht auch noch gleich in ansible reinzubringen
Dann hast du nämlich beim nächsten aufbau keine probleme das system wieder herzustellen
Also die zwei sachen du brauchst einmal eine backup snapshot lösung oder einfach nur ein paar
scripts für vmware, vsphere, was auch immer ihr da verwendet
und die möglichkeit software updates zu machen über ansible zum beispiel
und wenn es windows ist
Auf dem ihr unterwegs seid habe ich keine ahnung von weiß ich nicht was es da gutes gibt um windows zu updaten
Komme jetzt ins letzte lehrjahr hast ja bald geschafft viel spaß bei der prüfung
Ja, ja mir ist schon klar warum das so heißt ich finde das aber nur maximal unglücklich dass du das so zu nennen
Uyuni das kenne ich nicht was ist Uyuni?
github
Ah! Fork vom spacewalk
Spacewalk fork habe ich noch nie gehört obs
Ach ne open sooze build
Warum nennen die den kram obs? OBS ist für mich das hier und nicht open sooze build
vor allem open sooze bi- ob- ob- hä?
Oben?
Oben sooze
Oben sooze build und dddd ist dann auch desk driven design oder was?
Von windows software verteilung habe ich so keinen plan da wisst ihr wahrscheinlich im chat mehr
Und umso mehr prime subs umso mehr IQ umso mehr wissen noch was wie schreibt man ansible so
Ansible
Also kann ich dir aber hauptsächlich empfehlen wenn du linux basierte systeme hast wie gut ansible und windows in zusammenhang keine ahnung ansible
Wie gut funktioniert ansible mit windows?
Nichts was man machen will wahrscheinlich
Ach open sooze build system okay ne
Ne also ich wollte ich war gerade kurz dafür zu sagen
Für 50 prime subs überlege ich mir mal die sachen in rust zu rewriten aber das mache ich nicht also kommt nicht auf die idee
Jetzt das vielleicht wirklich zu machen erstens könnt ihr wahrscheinlich eure kohle besser gebrauchen und zweitens ich habe absolut keinen bock den kram in rust zu rewriten
Weil es auch so sinnlos ist weil ich in zukunft auch nicht maintain möchte in rust
Also ich habe mal puppet und windows versucht das war auch komplett für den arsch und ich glaube puppet supportet offiziell sogar windows
ja aber
Das ist nichts was ich empfehlen kann
In rust maintains ich das von alleine
Ja vielleicht vielleicht wenn die mods das dann maintain
aber leute
leute wenn wenn rewrite in rust ja
kenne ich nicht
Ist das ist das für windows oder was was soll das sein?
Aha okay
Was bin ich hier sehend
Avs laptop
Okay das ist das ist eher was für remote support
Na gut aber leute wenn wenn rust rewrite dann dann nicht rust sondern
kreplang oder
chat rust rewrite oder kreplang rewrite
Was was würden die die coolen krustentiere unter euch machen?
Weil das ist ja ein rust pork
Ich sehe schon das wird nichts mit dem rust rewrite
gut
So jetzt habe ich eine stunde im kreis gelabert
Jetzt müssen wir uns das langsam
Ich ich mag das font rendering in diesen java hilfe dialogen das sieht immer so schön nach 1985 aus
Falls man damals schon java ui machen konnte ich glaube das war altes java nicht
Ich muss noch eine sache sagen
Weil ich doch eben erzählt habe aus zeiten wo ich noch asubi war protokoll geschrieben habe und bei dir jemand gefragt danach windows
Automatisierung und ich habe ich habe gesagt ich kenne mich mit windows automatisierung nicht aus doch ich kenne eine sache noch aus meiner ausbildung
zum thema windows
Automatisierung und das hat mich wieder darin bestärkt dass ich nichts administratives mit windows zu tun haben will hatte jemand von euch schon mal
Ich weiß gar nicht ob sie software noch gibt ich suche jetzt mal einfach danach hat jemand von euch schon mal mit einer software namens
Altyris
Was zu tun gibt es das überhaupt noch
Softwaremanagement oder sowas
Ja, so ungefähr sah das aus genau
Da konnte man dann so start scripts boot scripts für windows hinterlegen und sowas das war ganz ganz abartig
Ich kann mich nur noch dunkel dran erinnern
Was wir in der software gemacht machen mussten aber es war eines der ekligsten experiences die ich die ich je mit so einer management software hatte
Und und seitdem bin ich froh nie wieder was mit windows administrativ zu tun gehabt haben
Sie nach einer software aus die ein rast rewrite benötigt
Bestimmt das rettet das rettet es komplett gibt es gibt es das altyris management suite
Jeden tag werden altyris administratoren angefragt computer aufzuladen neue software zu verteilen probleme zu lösen vieles mehr
Ja, wenn ich eine robuste management infrastruktur haben will dann nämlich so ein windows client only ding was hier auch noch
Moment moment leute leute ist das ist das etwa der internet explorer
Das fällt mir jetzt erst auf ist es ein tab im internet explorer
Ist das eine silverlight anwendung
Könnte das eine silverlight anwendung sogar noch sein
Ja ne ne
So nicht
So jetzt widmen wir uns aber wirklich in der kundling geschichte also do not import no pass
So
Disclaimer ich habe keine ahnung von java und ich habe keine ahnung von kotlin das heißt als allererstes werden sie
Mal ein hello world kopie also ich kann euch erzählen was wir versuchen werden zu machen und zwar
Wir bauen eine cli app und zumindest ist es der der plan dahinter wir bauen eine cli app der über
Http von irgendeiner wetter api das aktuelle wetter für den standort abfragt oder so was ich brauche ich brauche eine sinnlose
Sinnlose command line anwendung um ein bisschen auszuprobieren
Und wir gucken uns an wie man http request macht wie man kommandozeilen argumente passt wie man
Listen macht schleifen macht vielleicht generics verwendet
mal gucken
new project
Wahrscheinlich habe ich kotlin erstmal garten doch hier kommt mal kotlin no jdk
MonkaS download jdk moment man kann das direkt in der ide downloaden das finde ich extremly pog
das finde ich gut leute moment moment für den fall der fälle nur für den fall der fälle dass ich dass ich
Wenn man ein snapshot
Und bei der gelegenheit muss ich danach mal alle snapshots löschen sonst wird es ein bisschen viel
doch was er jetzt gemacht
Er ist halt doof wenn man kein window manager hatte kein fenster drum was ist das aktuelle jdk 20 wahrscheinlich
Okay download
Das ist extrem sick bei datacryp ist das auch kannst treiber für postgres man braucht treiber für postgres das ist mir neu
Ihr habt es heute mit eurem rust rewrite oder
Open jdk 20
21 haben die aber nicht zum download ich glaube es für uns erstmal egal
example code das ist gut bildsystem intelli j auch gut
Create git brauche ich jetzt nicht untitled
Java champ
Create
Das muss man den leuten bei kotlin ja bei jetbrains wirklich lassen
So wie nennt man es schon user experience oder programmer experience
Das kriegen die gut hin
Suggested plugins kubernetes terraform und hcl
Wir müssen erst mal wir müssen erst mal die schrift ein bisschen größer machen
Und
Ich will eigentlich die komplette schrift an umstellen wenn ich ehrlich bin vielleicht da
Appearance general und jetbrains mono 18
Ja das ist gut oder erkennt man eigentlich jetzt erkennt man gut was
Programm arguments hello world okay
Wie starte ich das jetzt
Also ich meine so ja aber
Programm aber wie starte ich das jetzt über cli
Also gehen wir mal gehen wir mal hier
Hier steht ja der aufruf wie das funktioniert guckt mal
Alter was was zum
Was ist das für ein ewig aufruf
Ich brauche mal kurz den kotlin quick quick start tutorial
Jet hat sich auf rust geeinigt ja
schön für den chat
Create and run an application perfekt
Kotlin c brauchen wir kotlin c hello kati und jetbrains
Kotlin c hello kati ok ok aber kotlin c habe ich gar nicht
Bild wo ist der bildknopf hier ich mache das normalerweise nicht über die idee
Ihr bild das hat mir jetzt aufgerufen zum bilden
Und wo hat der kotlin installiert
Mach einfach alles über die idee ok der beizeugnis java kenner dem glaube ich dass
shift f10 ist starten
Nee ich kann das ich will das nicht alles über die idee machen ich will ich will eine command line anwendung bauen das ist
vergessen
Aber man konnte doch wenn ich das richtig
Run with parameters ok
Moment also man hatte doch früher hier in der idee so eine sache settings edit configurations
Ok wie heißt das ding kotlin c
Wo hat dann das installiert das muss er doch irgendwo installiert haben ist das ist das irgendwie bild in in intelli j oder
Ja das bild tab aber ich weiß nicht ich weiß nicht wo
Mit rust wäre das nicht passiert
Eben hatte ich doch hier noch einen anderen output drinne wo ist der ursprüngliche rerun bild
Ach so das ist weil es im cache ist jetzt
Ok da kommt jetzt einfach noch ein lehrzeichen rein und dann das bild noch mal laufen lassen
Ja
Also der hat kotlin kotlin jvm ausgeführt ich meine das muss ja irgendwie unter jdk liegen
jdks open jdk bin
ne
geht geht schon mal gut los
Weil irgendwo hier muss es ja liegen
aha
What
Jetzt seriously ja
Gibt es da gibt es wenigstens eingebautes cli hier
Wieso ich das über das terminal machen will naja dass ich ich baue ja eine terminal ich baue eine terminalanwendung
Dass ich dann sowas machen kann am ende ja keine ahnung java gem minus minus blob minus minus
So was man kann zwar hier auch einstellen parameters aber das doch
Ist doch nix
na gut
Anscheinend anscheinend müssen wir es wirklich
der java champ
Anscheinend müssen wir es wirklich so machen
ja
Local share
Ja und jetzt hello gibt es da nicht sowas wie run
Gibt es gibt es nicht run
Ich glaube ich mache es doch über die ide das
Das regt mich schon auf dass das so jetzt hatte ich meinen helft nicht meine hilfe alle ach in der java macht java welt macht man
nicht minus minus
Okay leute ich ich sehe schon ich macht es doch über die ide
Ich werde ich werde es doch über die ide machen so und wo finde ich jetzt den output davon out hier
Moment
Okay es geht schon es geht schon gut los und dann muss ich das hier starten monka giga alda
Wie kompiliere ich das denn jetzt zu irgendwas was ich ausführen kann zu irgendeiner selbst self-contained sache wie mit dort net
Wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich gar nicht so ohne weiteres
Du musst das zu einer java datei machen kann man kann man ok kotlin self-contained
machen kein rast
kotlin native
Ja jetzt kommen gleich die advancen themen
How to get started get started with kotlin multiplattform
Include run time ja aber da kommt eine java datei raus eine java datei kann man doch nicht einfach ausführen eine java datei kann man ausführen mit
wenn wenn java installiert ist
Nein wir machen kein rast chat
Ist ja schlimm heute
Intelli j benutzen wir ok ok
Aber wir müssen kotlin multiplattform auswählen warum ist das schon wieder so eine wissenschaft für sich
Irgendwas
dort
überhaupt zu kompilieren
Für kotlin brauchst du immer noch ja aber kann man die run time irgendwie embedden dass man java nicht mehr braucht
Die haben hier irgendwas irgendwas stand damit include run time aber aber include run time
Ja das ist die kotlin run time die die included ist das ist nicht die java run also nicht da ist nicht die
Jvm geschichten da braucht man immer noch java
Na gut ich meine wie dem auch sei da machen wir das ganze halt rein über die ide
Aber das schon mal nicht so nicht so klar wie ich das gerne hätte
Ja genau und die jar kannst du ja nur mit java ausführen ich hätte gerne so komplett komplett self-contained anwendung
Okay also wo woher dann meine erste frage die ich habe woher kommt überhaupt print line ist das so eine globale
kotlin internal inline only
Alles okay print line alias zu system out print line
Okay, das ist gar nicht. So übel ich finde es gar nicht. So blöd dass das included ist
Weil
ansonsten hast du
Die scharfeste console right line und du hast es auch immer included also insofern
So also probieren wir es mal aus hier
print
brindeln
wisst ihr eine sache
Die ich extrem nice finden würde wenn
Programmiersprachen und standard und libraries die
Mit dieser print print line und sowas geschichte anfangen dass so ein bisschen eher so z
Go zum beispiel ist glaube ich so was oder heißt es heißt es in go auch
print f
Die format ist aber format print f genau also
Was ich was ich cool finden würde ist wenn libraries die print f mitbringen auch print f mitbringen würden klingt jetzt bescheuert
Ich glaube es gibt kaum was
Was das hat aber mich nervt es immer ungemein von hand new lines schreiben zu müssen
Und warum warum warum kein print f effeln wenn man schon printen hat
Okay, auto complete und das ganze zeug fühlt sich natürlich mal wieder richtig richtig nice an ich meine es ist von von jet brains für
jet brains
So wie kann man sich jetzt anzeigen lassen
Message ahja
Kecke
Komma
Okay und weitere sachen hat moment kann jetzt haben wir schon mal das erste kann
Kann kotlin string interpolation also war blubb gleich 1 ich gehe nicht davon aus dass wie das funktioniert
Legt man wirklich so variablen an den kotlin das war jetzt einfach mal
first try okay
So geht jetzt sowas wie kecke
Blubb nee
Kecke blubb nee
Was könnte es denn sonst noch sein
Kotlin string interpolation
Machst wie in zeile 8
Ach hier ich bin ja
Bin blind oder sogar unten drunter ein beispiel am start
weg damit
Okay, nicht schlecht finde ich ganz nice
Redundant curly braces
Auch so einfach
Okay und wenn ich und wenn ich dann wirklich den dollar haben will dann es käbe ich das wahrscheinlich
Warum nicht finde ich eigentlich ganz schick
Chat ist heute wieder richtig high IQ ja
Finde ich eigentlich ganz gut okay
So als nächstes wie machen wir eine liste
War list gleich und es ist es ist bestimmt nicht new list gehe ich mal von aus
list
kotlin collections
list of
Nee so funktioniert es schon mal nicht
List of
Kotlin list example
Kottel ist exampel
Wort
list of
Warum nicht ist gewöhnungssache ja okay
Ich finde es immer ein bisschen komisch wenn es so eigene
sagen so eigene bild in sachen gibt zum erstellen von typen anstatt
irgendwas mit den typen selbst
Aber es ist wahrscheinlich gewöhnungssache
Komma der erkennt sogar gleich dass es eine liste auf in sein soll das finde ich gut das gefällt mir das finde ich schick
Und jetzt bin ich mal gespannt wenn ich eine liste ausgebe was macht er dann
In c sharp würde der jetzt ausgeben dass es hier instance of list quasi macht er in kotlin wahrscheinlich das gleiche
hallo shift f10
Nee oh guck mal der ist richtig schlau der macht aus der liste gleich einen debug baren string
Das ist nice das finde ich gut
Also in internet ich muss euch das jetzt mal zum vergleich das finde ich wirklich cool dass er stand hat mich sowas eingebaut hat
Ich muss es jetzt mal zum vergleich zeigen
Konsole app 2 bester name überhaupt
Ist cute cute chatter app ja also in
Alter
Rider kriegt ich mal ein
Wo ist das problem unload
load
aus
Irgendwelchen gründen ist das total kaputt aber das ist eh nix was wir brauchen deswegen schmeiß ich mal wieder weg
Konsole right line
So und das ding ist halt in c sharp müsste ich sowas machen
Also mal angenommen ich habe ich mache ich mache hier genau ich mache quasi mal genau das gleiche in c sharp
Also mal sowas hier war list da müsste ich gleich eine new list
Hier muss ich auf jeden fall schon mal angeben list von ind 1 2 3 5 6 7 oder 1 2 3 4
Siehste siehste schon wieder gebetet worden so 1 2 3 4
Und ich glaube den kann man weglassen mittlerweile
Und wenn ich das jetzt wenn ich hier das gleiche sagen will dann müsste ich sowas hier machen hecke doppelpunkt und jetzt könnte ich sagen
List in dort net passiert jetzt aber folgendes muss man kurz hier rein rider projects console app 2
. net
. net run
Ja, ich bin im falschen ordner ok
Guck der würde jetzt sagen kecke und das ist der typ und nicht die liste an sich
Und nein und selbst to string hilft nicht das ist ja nämlich das was hier was hier nicht
To string hilft nicht das ist genau das gleiche da kommt nichts aus wenn ich wirklich wenn ich wirklich die zahlen hier
Ausgeben will dann müsste ich jetzt sowas machen wie
String join
Liste
nie zuerst separator
separator liste
So wenn ich glück habe funktioniert es jetzt
ja hier guck
Das ist da muss ich ehrlich sagen da ist es deutlich cooler gelöst in kotlin an der stelle
dass er so basic basic sachen direkt in debug bares strings zurück übersetzt
Go hat aber das problem dass go keine string interpolation gescheit unterstützt oder kann es
Mittlerweile ich glaube nicht go hat immer noch dieses eklige print f zeug überall
Okay, das gefällt mir schon mal ganz gut
Das ist
Es ist jetzt nicht so als wäre das hier wahnsinnig unlesbar und unverwendbar aber ganz gut hier, okay
nächster punkt
Wie macht man eine schleife in go
Ähnlich in go wie komme ich auf go in kotlin vor
Hat man da auch irgendwelche hilfen vielleicht vor
Ich probiere jetzt mal was vor i in list
Okay die sprache ist intuitiv
Sind
Die sprache ist intuitiv ich wusste nicht wie das aussehen muss und ich bin gleich drauf gekommen
nice
Und jetzt ist die frage
Wie würde man eine ganz normale
Kann man in kotlin die schleife die klammern weglassen
Wahrscheinlich auch nur wenn es einzeilig ist
Wie machst du eine normale schleife die zählt ja das das das frage ich mich auch gerade ich meine vielleicht
Vielleicht kann kotlin auch die standard syntakt sowas wie war ich probiert es jetzt einfach mal ich habe keine ahnung wie das aussieht
war i gleich 0
Komma i kleiner 10 plus plus
I kleiner 10 i plus plus
Okay kotlin kauen mit ranges
Guckte mal
Vor i in 0 until ok
Vor also i in 0 until und jetzt 10 oder wie
Was sagt okay
Was sagt rider dazu until can be replaced
Okay das ist cool
Okay, da sagt man okay vor i in 0
bis kleiner 10
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich coole syntakt dafür
Und wenn ich das weglassen ist es wahrscheinlich inklusive 10 ja sie sieht man ja auch hier inklusive 10
Und was ist wenn ich hier sowas dran machen da geht es natürlich
Oder gleich da man gleich machen
Das ist das ist cool warum du noch java schreibst das weiß ich auch nicht
Vielleicht weil du alte projekte hast die halt komplett in java sind
Ich weiß nicht wie es mit der kompatibilität zwischen kotlin und java aussieht also ich vermute mal dass
Alles gültige in java also nicht synthax aber libraries und so auch gültiges kotlin sind
Und ich vermute umgedreht gilt das auch weil das letztendlich ja alles auf der jvm läuft also
Wahrscheinlich sind die dinge eins zu eins austauschbar jetzt halt nicht source code mäßig sondern nur
auf der ebene untendrunter
Ja wenn es kobold für jvm gebe dann auch
Mal eine frage hast du schon design patterns wie mvvm oder mvc und das ja habe ich
Allerdings ich habe noch nie eine mvvm app gebaut die ein bisschen größer war und ich fand es auch immer extrem
anstrengend
in wpf
Wpf ist schon ziemlich blutet und mit der ganzen viewmodel geschichte ist das wahrscheinlich eher was für business enterprise enterprise apps
Wenn ich was in wpf gemacht habe muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen code behind datei und gut ist also zur erklärung
mvvm ist model
view viewmodel
Und mvc ist model viewcontroller also mvc selber habe ich schon total oft verwendet auch mit asp.net core
Oder mit ruby on rails damals schon so ziemlich jedes halbwegs modernere back-end web framework unterstützt mvc
Die sind bei asp.net core ein bisschen davon weggekommen vom klassischen mvc aber ist immer noch sehr verbreitet und mvvm ist eher was für
ui
ui frameworks
Da kenne ich mich aber nicht so wirklich aus
Also ich weiß nur dass man sagt gerade was wpf angeht dass man sagt mvvm ist dort relativ beliebt
wegen data bindings und dynamischen ui
also dass du quasi
in deinem model quasi so die unterliegende nennen wir es mal logik hast
So die business logik wie man das glaube ich so schön nennt von deiner anwendung dann hast du einen view
Das ist die reine ui und mit dem viewmodel
Bereitest du quasi das was du hier in deiner business logik drin hast so auf dass es dein view ordentlich verwalten und ordentlich
verwenden kann
Also mal angenommen mal ein simples beispiel ja du hast irgendeine logik für geld
Rein mit irgendwie einem float, anzeige
Geld kann das ui nichts anfangen dann würdest du den viewmodel dazwischen packen was aus
Diesem betrag hier ja keine ahnung
ein betrag gerundet in euro macht mit einem euro zeichen schön das display bar dahinter
Und ein dein view würde das einfach nur binden das viewmodel und eins zu eins
Durchreichen mit kleinen ui anpassungen so soweit ist glaube ich der gedanke hinter mvvm
Ohne es jetzt bei größeren apps selbst verwendet zu haben
Oder snibbi was sagst du dazu?
Gut widmen wir uns zwar weiter kotlin es gibt es gibt ein paar ganz gute bücher dazu
Ich habe
Irgendwo auch eins für wpf wartet mal lasst mich mal um die ecke
Ich habe ich habe es gefunden das ist ein buch mit irgendwie 3000 seiten oder so ohne übertreibung das heißt wpf das ultimative
Ich habe ich habe schon wieder vergessen
Das
umfassende handbuch
so
mega fettes ding
Keine ahnung ob das noch aktualisiert wird
Das umfassende handbuch auch hier da gibt es ein bisschen was neues das hat einfach mal
1218 seiten
Wpf und irgendwo da wird auch auf mvvm eingegangen weil ich das richtig in erinnerung habe
Ich habe mir das buch damals gekauft weil ich damals noch scharf drauf war wpf zu laufen die die erste ausgabe ist von keiner
2006 oder so weil ich da noch irgendwie scharf drauf war wpf zu lernen ich habe es nie gelesen
Ich habe es nie gelesen habe ich auch keinen bock drauf bin ich gar nicht dass
das buchform zum lernen von solchen basics
Unsinnig ist dass den riesen vorteil in buchform hast ist dass es oftmals ordentlich durchdacht und gescheit aufbereitet ist
Nee das erklärt dir wirklich dass das ist kein nachschlag
Referenz nachschlag ist sinnlos in buchform da gebe ich dir recht das ist was zum lernen
Da kriegst du die unterschiedlichen wpf konzepte erklärt
Aber wie gesagt ich habe das buch nie gelesen ich weiß nicht ob es was taugt
Und für mvvm im
mit wpf ich gehe mal davon aus sie sollte das in wpf machen weil das wpf ist so ziemlich das einzige desktop
Was mir einfällt vielleicht aber lohnt ja noch weil es wpf bisschen nachempfunden ist wo mvvm so ein ding ist
Okay weiter wir eigentlich sind wir nicht hier um auf wpf zu lässt ansonsten uns kotlin anzugucken so also pokers schleife gemacht nächster punkt
Wenn wir okay lass noch mal eine andere sache ausprobieren ich gehe mal davon aus wenn wir eine schleife machen können
aus
Jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt das gibt kein fehler
Was ist denn das jetzt
Das kann ja kein list of int mehr sein
Das ist ein list of ein moment ein ein was ein list of comparable sternchen
What jetzt jetzt wird es interessant was ist das jetzt
Und was ist mein i
Mein is ein
comparable sternchen auf
javas serial labels
What the fuck
Ist das ist das quasi jetzt list of object im endeffekt ist das im endeffekt sowas hier
Moment wie kann das jetzt eine list of int sein
Weil das kompiliert das
Object
Interessant dass es funktioniert
Das das macht unter der haube ja aber aber was aber was ist das denn jetzt
Das ist sowas wie ein objekt im endeffekt oder
Kann ich kann ich das kasten zu einem objekt
gibt gibt es überhaupt ein objekt in
Und wie kastet man
Fragen überfragen
Kann man denn okay jetzt jetzt probieren wir mal was jetzt okay das ist vielleicht ein bisschen
Advanceres topic aber das müssen wir jetzt mal ausprobieren also wir haben jetzt hier quasi so eine liste auf objekt sowas in der richtung
Und wir haben jetzt nur von diesem interface
Das war item sonst haben wir jetzt zwar nicht wirklich
Die item ist vom typ comparable
Gibt es jetzt sowas wie dass ich checken kann
Ich vermute mal dass hier sind list
To let run das sind wahrscheinlich sachen was alle listen haben nehmen wenn das ja gar keine liste
Okay, wie kastet man sachen in
kotlin cast
any to object
Jetzt okay
Aha
Aha man macht das
Das ist so ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie die pattern matching if geschichte in c sharp würde ich mal sagen
Okay, das ist gar nicht. Das ist eigentlich relativ cool gemacht
Also ich würde jetzt ich würde jetzt quasi sagen
Wir nennen das mal item und nicht ich würde jetzt quasi sagen
Item ist string string groß oder klein
string groß
Brindeln
Was mich ein bisschen verwirrt ist warum setzt er mich hier eigentlich nicht in die mitte rein
Und jetzt ist item an der stelle ist item ein string
Doch jetzt ist item den string an der stelle guckt mal
Jetzt habe ich nämlich auch längst und und jazz und alles mögliche am start
Das ist wirklich cool was ist wenn ich jetzt in der b gleich item ist dann benen string auch comparable deshalb komisch
Aber wie kastet man dann ist nämlich danke für den start wie kastet man denn von hand
Außer mit
Wenn expressions okay, das ist jetzt die pattern matching geschichte das muss uns auch gleich angucken es
also quasi
Okay, war blubb gleich item s
string
Und blubb ist jetzt ein swing, okay
Das müsste jetzt eigentlich crashen weil du
Ind nicht so quasi implizit casten kannst zu einem string oder kann kotlin das ruft es dann zu string auf
Ja
Integer cannot be cast to string das fällt mich jetzt auch gewundert wenn das geht
Irgendwie triggert sich der gnu in den style ich weiß nicht ob es der gnu in den style ist ich finde den aber viel nicer
Als die go geschichte in go würde das ganze ja also in go
Also nur mal so zum vergleich check wenn wir jetzt in go also so würde das ganze auch in c sharp by the way aussehen ja
in go in go
Würde ihr könnt mir mal sagen gleich was ihr schöner findet so das ist ja so der normale style in anscheinend kotlin auch
preferred und und c sharp standartmäßig auch
In go würde das ganze so aussehen
Das ist zwar kürzer, aber ich muss ehrlich sagen ich finde es eklig
Viel besser
Ich bin klammer in eigener zeile auch besser so wir müssen übrigens noch eine sache einstellen die mich nervt und zwar
Wir wollen nicht wir wollen nicht vor spaces haben wir wollen to spaces haben
Und jetzt wollen wir reformat machen
Also zwei sachen irritieren mich hier schon mal
Erstens warum hat kotlin diesen hässlichen klammer style standardmäßig
und zweitens
warum entdeckte das nicht mit
nicht mit vier spaces
mit zwei spaces
Aber hier geht es doch auch
Hä was ist das für ein scheiß?
Ich es gibt ein menü und es passiert nichts wenn ich umstelle
Ich an in dente das einfach mal alles und jetzt bin ich mal gespannt was es da
Eins passt mal auf eins
Das juckt es juckt es einfach nicht
Juckt es juckt es einfach nicht
Muss neu formatieren habe ich doch schon 500 mal gemacht
Also ich meine ich kann es jetzt so lassen aber
Vielleicht steht das im projekt so konfiguriert drinne
aber
Okay kotlin change indentation
Intelligent
Also in rider ist das gar kein ding guck hier leute
Ich habe das
Club
Guckt ich habe das gleich so umgestellt dass das hier
to spaces
Gar kein gar kein problem gewesen
Moment sieht ja anders aus bomben also anscheinend anscheinend geht das geht das nicht
anscheinend
Also ich meine das muss aber das muss doch möglich sein schau mal ganz unten rechts meinst das hier
Da habe ich doch von 500 marken geklickt
Coding style
Wo ist kotlin hier zur auswahl gar nicht ja meine güte
general
Deswegen gibt es hier kotlin gar nicht zur auswahl
Bei coding style doch da kotlin so jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
Da habe ich den coding style umgestellt
Reformat
Nein das juckt es einfach nicht
Okay, bevor wir uns jetzt mit dem kram aufhalten dann bleibt es halt eben bei vier spaces
Vielleicht ist es auch verbuggt
Vielleicht kotlin vorgabe das würde mich wundern
Mich nervt übrigens auch dass es das ist das
Kompiliert kotlin wenigstens ja man nicht schlecht wenn man die klammern so macht im vergleich zu go
Ja gut das kann nicht funktionieren
Okay, wenigstens wenigstens kompiliert kotlin go sagt ja bei sowas wenn die klammern falsch gesagt falsch gesetzt sind
Oh, nee das geht überhaupt nicht dass da kann ich nicht kompilieren
Was ist das eigentliche ding was ich was ich was ich ausprobieren wollte genau also guck mal also wir können implizit
Quasi item zu string casten das finde ich schon mal eine coole sache wir probieren das jetzt noch mal noch mal anders aus wir
Machen jetzt ein int rein wir machen jetzt ein float rein und wir machen jetzt
Hat das sowas wie null oh nee damit will ich nicht anfangen
Buhl genau true true lul weh machen wir da jetzt rein
Das ist die einzige ausgabe die jetzt kommt ist bei
1 weil das das einzige ist was mit string hat jetzt ist die frage hat link sowas hat hat kotlin sowas wie link
dass ich sage wer oder oder filter oder
Interessant filter
Jetzt kommt das ding wie sieht die lambda sündags für kotlin aus
kotlin list filter
Kotlin gibt das vor ernsthaft
Mann also ich mag zwei space ist einfach deutlich mehr als vier mit filtering collections
Sieht wie aus
Achso guck mal man muss gar nicht selbst parameter das finde ich schick
Also wenn man einfach nur ein parametern kann man nicht nehmen
Ansonsten kann man relativ ähnlich zur c sharp syntax
Das nehmen okay
Also ich kann es in dem fall sagen
Type die it is string geht sowas
Jetzt sagt er filter call could be simplified
So
Okay, also das muss man da sagen da merkt man dass jetbrains die sprache
Und die idee macht dass das so gut funktioniert dass sie die alternative vorschlagen können
Okay, das bedeutet nämlich auch wenn ich das so machen das war mal eine probabler schleife war mal print
brindeln
Und dann sage ich wie count oder sowas count
Wenn das hier auch geht count
Da sollte jetzt rauskommen eins obwohl ja eigentlich vier elemente drin sind
Nice okay gut das heißt die haben so ein bisschen link light nennen wir es mal mit in kotlin drinne
Das finde ich ganz geil mach mal eine nested list
Jetzt sowas hier list of
So geht doch
Das ist jetzt das ist jetzt eine nested list
Ich meine den string wird er natürlich aus der nested list nicht erkennen
Ich meine was was wir jetzt in c sharp machen könnte ist select many neben bei mir das wieder
Und das würde an der stelle gar nicht funktionieren weil das weiß er nicht welches objekt das ist okay da müssen wir jetzt
Okay da müssen wir noch mal eine schleife ich finde es aber ganz also ich muss ehrlich sagen das wirkt auf mich
bis jetzt relativ durchdacht alles
Ja, habe ich auch schon gerade dran gedacht
flat 8 tatsächlich
Flat map
Eine sache die mir noch ein bisschen fehlt ist ein hilfetext was das eigentlich macht
Oder kann man sich mit dem hilfetext anzeigen lassen
quick doch a control q
Control q da kriegt man sogar eine hilfe
Returns a single list of all elements yield from result of transform function ja okay das könnte man an der stelle natürlich
machen
das tatsächlich
Das ist gar nicht gar nicht so
Blöde an der stelle okay machen wir noch mal print
Print l item
Ja so und jetzt geht
zu string das
Im moment was mache ich hier überhaupt
Aber ich will ich will ja eigentlich gar nicht flat map oder platt
Returns a single list of all elements
Ne das müsste doch müsste schon funktionieren
da muss nun
Iterable rauskommen also quasi wie list of it
Okay das funktioniert es kann aber nicht den uns weg der sache sein oder
Ich bin mir nicht sicher wie ich den krempel verhalten muss aber ich finde die funktion schon mal so und jetzt hier müsste ich jetzt
quasi checken
Kann man hier kann man hier multiline drinnen machen
Ja, okay, also hier müsste ich jetzt quasi drin
Drinnen checken wenn das eine liste ist
Also quasi if kann man den if drinnen machen
if
Ne da muss man muss man vielleicht noch mal klammern
Wie macht man mehrere zeilen damit
Kotlin multiline
Wir sind wir haben jetzt leider die isi themen übersprungen
Ach da muss man das mit function direkt machen
Also anstatt so quasi
What ne man muss das mit so einem komischen pfeil machen hat okay
Moment dass das das überfordert mich jetzt
List zwei besser besser name überhaupt
Dass das überfordert mich jetzt irgendwie dies was sie mir hier mitteilen wollen
Das muss jetzt in mehrere zeilen sein oder
Return oder
Okay das checken wir das funktionieren soll list of
Und
Ohne return
Also geht das okay, okay, das erinnert mich ein bisschen an die gruvi sündags die finde ich aber nicht so schön jetzt
Also gar nicht so schlecht so und dann haben wir noch eine alternative multiline da macht man das mit function okay
Also da würde ich jetzt quasi sagen
Dann würde ich so sagen und dann fangt schon
E
List of
Return
List for each function wieso ist doch richtig so
Dann check ich die sündags nicht das habe ich doch richtig gemacht
Wir machen es mal so wie es funktioniert hat weil eigentlich wollte ich was anderes ausprobieren und zwar
Und eigentlich wollte der chat da ich was anderes ausprobieren so also wir müssen jetzt gucken
Ist eine liste oder
Ihn innamorabel
Collection muss ich wahrscheinlich gucken oder
Wenn es eine collection ist
Ne das funktioniert so nicht und das haben wir so else
Return
List of
List of e
Warum ist es jetzt warum ist es jetzt problem?
So funktioniert es doch
Das ist nicht
Ich ich returne doch in beiden fällen was
Ach, nee, ich habe nicht in beiden fällen was okay, also das wird das wird so funktionieren
Nur das wird nicht hier checken sondern hier müssen wir auf collection checken das funktioniert so nicht
Use collections
Sternchen aha
Interessant so da sollte jetzt noch nichts machen aber sollte immer noch funktionieren so und das heißt wenn das jetzt eine collection ist
Dann gebe ich nicht list auf zurück sondern direkt die collection
cool
Okay, nice. Also ich muss sagen die haben das recht intuitiv gestaltet
Ich habe noch nie was mit kotlin vorher gemacht und komme eigentlich relativ intuitiv mit mit den sachen klar
Das spricht für die sprache muss man sagen
So und wie sie wie würde das korrekt formatiert aussehen so na ja
Man kann an der stelle wahrscheinlich übrigens auch die klammern ups
Man kann an der stelle wahrscheinlich sogar die ganzen klammern auch
Vermutlich weglassen
Weil es ist ja nur
Online
Kann man nicht
Dann weiß er nicht wo doch doch das kapiert aber das sieht jetzt schon ziemlich hässlich aus oder
Das das sieht jetzt da sieht er schon ziemlich hässlich aus
Ich meine wir könnten auch so was machen hier mal gucken ob das mal gucken ob das funktioniert
Das da also wenn das eine collection ist dann eh ansonsten list auf
Nee kotlin ternary operator hat kotlin sowas
Nee nee
Okay macht aber nix in der elvis operator
Nee nee das ist was anderes das ist was anderes
Der checkt ob der er checkt ob das null ist wenn das nicht null ist gibt es dann dafür den das quasi ein null check im
Endeffekt
Also sprich aber wir können if kann man aber auch online mäßig benutzen anscheinend
Warum braucht man eigentlich keinen return hier davor
der benutzt weil der weil der immer
ist
Das das letztmögliche aus dem execution so fahrt quasi
Hä na gut
Was soll es ja auch sonst sein wenn es einzeln dasteht als den return du machst ja sonst nix damit
So aber ich könnte es ich könnte es wahrscheinlich so schreiben
Ja
Das das geht doch eigentlich voll klar
Und jetzt bräuchte ich wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal die multiline geschichte
Wenn ich anstatt e it verwende
Geht doch eigentlich echt klar
Und jetzt könnte man das sogar an der stelle hier reinschreiben oder auch nicht warum nicht doch geht doch
Ah ja ich habe schon hässlicheres gesehen
Das mit dem sternchen finde ich vielleicht ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig aber so siehst du wenigstens gleich dass das irgendein generic type ist
Was wird hier erstellt gar nix wir gucken uns kotlin an
sonst nix weiter
Ja, also ich muss sagen finde ich finde das
Ich finde das bis jetzt eigentlich ganz ganz nice
Ich finde ich finde das mit dem sternchen auch nicht so schlecht
Okay, da haben wir uns jetzt schon mal so ein bisschen die basics angeguckt finde ich bis ich finde es wirklich nicht übel bis
Jetzt muss ich sagen es hat was hat was
Okay, wir können schleifen wir können listen wie ändert man dann was in der liste das soll man vielleicht auch noch list
Push auch Gott sei dank nicht
Zum glück zum glück ist nicht push das hat mich ja viel zu fair als sie bloß bloß erzielt das bloß erinnert
Ändert man überhaupt was oder ist es im mutable und ich muss eine neue liste machen
ich brauche eine mutable list of list of
Mutable list
Warum nicht okay
Jetzt gibt es auch
Ich vermute mal man kann den index weglassen
Ja, das haben die wirklich leute wisst ihr was
Bei c++ wäre es jetzt so gewesen du kannst den index nicht nicht wenn ich kann ich den index weglassen
Ja kann ich bei c++ wäre es jetzt so gewesen ich kann den index nicht weglassen
Und c++ hätte dann so sachen wie pushback push push front und sowas
Weil hat was heißt hätte c++ hat sowas
Das gefällt mir das hat was das ist gut durchdacht also dann da merkst du dass das jemand designt hat der ein bisschen ein bisschen
entwickler
freundlichkeit im hinterkopf hatte
Also nicht wie c++ sondern das c++ gremium
So gucken wir uns jetzt mal was anderes an wie macht man http requests
Mal gleich mal mal mal gleich mal in einen sprung http client nein doch
Jetzt kommen java shit aber das kann kotlin http request die haben doch bestimmt aber was besseres eingebaut
Kotlin http requests jawohl http get
Ne das ist irgendeine custom library die ich nicht haben will oder
ne
Http client ist doch richtig ne ne ne man muss das java zeug verwenden anscheinend
Http client es gibt noch ein paar extra libraries aber das muss ja muss ja nicht sein es gibt tausend
Extra libraries ok probieren wir mal ok wir probieren mal den http client zu verwenden
Http client new http client ok
Was will der hier von mir das remove http client nee warum?
Http client get nee so einfach ist es schon mal nicht
send
Moment send vielleicht
Jetzt
Jetzt hört schon auf http get request kotlin
Okay guckt man sich das beispiel noch mal an
ja
Request ok man braucht ein extra request man kann nicht einfach http client get machen kann man vielleicht http client get so
Da braucht man ein request
New nee request oder was
Ups ich fand es das
Http request http request
Nehmen wir mal wetter.in
Da will ich jetzt http requesten oder hatten die nicht wetter.in hatten die nicht auch irgendeine jason api
jason
Detroit das wollen wir haben
Oder nicht detroit komm
Frankfurt frankfurt
Checkt er dass ich das in deutschland mein frankfurter meine alles checkt da
So funktioniert es schon mal nicht alles klar
Uri create
Uri
create
String
Okay das funktioniert was ich hier versuche war
was zu
war request gleich
War das jetzt auto rename to
request
Warum mache ich da eigentlich ist die kolons hinten dran
so request
Kunstnet warum nicht
weil
Type mismatch ach so muss ich da irgendwie noch die bild sagen hinten dran
Also die marken http request http response body handlers of
What was soll das sein was ist das sind http
Responses nicht einfach immer bytes
Ach so das ist okay jetzt verstehe ich könnte das ich könnte quasi das automatisch pausen lassen schon in irgendwas
Also standardmäßig kriegst du ja bytes zurück so und das kann ich das quasi als utf-8 string interpretieren lassen
Ich könnte es aber wahrscheinlich auch als irgendein strukt oder oder vielleicht so vielleicht sogar irgendwelche
Irgendwelches jason pausen lassen an der stelle keine ahnung aber zumindest ich finde ich finde es ein bisschen
Ja bis ich undurchsichtig
So jetzt haben wir das gesendet
Und jetzt okay ganz ehrlich da finde ich den den dort net hat http klein sogar ein bisschen angenehmer in der handhabung
Weil da kriege ich hier kann ich kann ich euch gleich zeigen da kriege ich hier ein ordentliches response objekt
Wenn wenn der auch nicht dabei ist als letzter schluss ist ja
okay brindeln
brindeln
Request
und jetzt kann ich sowas sagen wie
Anni nicht wie response ja doch doch dann ist es ja ähnlich zu dem dort net klein response
Body und er ist jetzt ist schon ein string oder wie
Hä aber wenn man body doch keins dann verstehe ich den sinn davon nicht oder ist checkt er jetzt dass das ein string ist
Weil ich weiß nicht ob wo er soll ich woher soll ich wissen was body für einen typ ist
Das sagt mir es ist ein generic type aber nicht was es in diesem fall ist
Okay, was ist blob für das ist ein string
okay
Also er checkt schon dass es ein string ist aber er zeigt es mir hier an der stelle
Nicht an dass es ein string ist
Ich weiß woher das kommt also gehe ich mal statt dass es von der aber warum zeigt mir das meine idee nicht an
Wenn man hier jetzt eigentlich erwartet returns the body beste hilfe fehlermeldung überhaupt
returns the body
Also leute es gibt den körper zurück auf gut deutsch
Ja ich finde körper zurück zurückgebende funktionen sind die besten
hat nicht funktionierend
Uri will undy feinski ach so ich muss
Undy feinski ach so ich muss http ist https
https
Chat meinte es funktioniert jetzt muss man kurz ich muss mal kurz was in die e-mails gucken bei mir am zweiten monitor
Abchecken
Okay fertig okay check mal was funktioniert
Funktioniert okay nice
Jetzt haben wir jetzt haben wir die http response also ich muss sagen ich finde ich finde es aber trotzdem noch ein bisschen ekelig in
Der bedienung ich zeige euch das jetzt mal parallel wie man das in c-sharp machen würde da würde ich sagen war
Http wir machen das mal so ähnlich wie hier jetzt http klang new http client
So hier könnte ich jetzt irgendwelche basics sachen noch setzen am http kleinen standard header oder sowas aber lassen wir das mal lassen wir das mal
außen vor
So und jetzt sage ich in dort net einfach http klein get async
Und dann
Und dann meine url
Response so
Das finde ich doch irgendwie etwas angenehmer und wenn ich das ausgeben will sage ich war
Ups
Response ich glaube hier geht es da auch mit content und dann string read as string
Meine es könnte bestimmt auch noch ein bisschen schöner sein aber insgesamt muss ich sagen
Oder ja was denkt ihr leute was ist einfach oder was ist angenehmer zu entwickeln so hier oder
So hier ich meine es ist im prinzip nur eine zeile mehr
Nimmt sich jetzt nicht viel aber ich finde es von der klarheit her
In c-sharp tatsächlich ein bisschen angenehmer als hier java standard zeug
Du kannst noch eine extension function für den http klein schreiben
die essig
Du musst nicht essen gewählt machen du könntest theoretisch auch
so machen
Wenn du es ohne essen gewählt machen willst kannst du so machen
Aber es ist halt dafür ausgelegt das stimmt schon
Macht das ganze mal synchron. Ja hier jetzt ist synchron
Die zwar ein bisschen ekliger aus gut. Ich meine die ap ist halt rein für s und ausgelegt was wir da machen
Ich verstehe dieses ganze single welt konzept irgendwie nicht okay
Also, dann versuche ich das mal ganz kurz zu erklären in java script ist es tatsächlich einfach
einfacher mit essen gewählt weil in java script
Hast du nur einen thread
Jetzt mal du musst dir du musst dir keine gedanken drüber machen ob das irgendwie sich in die quere kommt
In c-sharp hast du einen thread pool und essen gewählt was du hast quasi beides so ein bisschen kombiniert
also was das hier macht
Wir müssten das vielleicht ein bisschen umschreiben nur so zur erklärung was was das hier macht ist folgendes
Man könnte es vielleicht auch eher
return await oder so nennen
also gedacht ist es in der welt dafür dass du
Asynchronen code schreiben kannst wie synchron
Und ich nicht selbst um callbacks kümmern musst also ich ich zeig dir das mal ich zeig dir mal was
Anstatt das mit essen zu machen
Machen wir mal ein beispiel ich weiß ich hatte ja war auch so was in der richtung wenn ich wenn ich kann man sich das
Gleiche für java script denken also
Wir machen das ganze mal ohne essen gewählt okay und auch ohne
Forciertes synchron sein du könntest ohne await auch sagen continue with
Response da müssen wir das hier aber wegmachen
Response
So das wird ein bisschen ekliger zu lesen aber dann siehst du wahrscheinlich was passiert ja und dann wird zu sagen response
Hab ich mich irgendwo vertan? ach result muss ich machen ja okay weil es ein task ist
Response nennen wir es mal so hier irgendwie keine ahnung
Task wenn es einfach task mal so ist so
Result response dann würde ich sagen response
Content
Response
Read a string äh sing und dann würde ich wieder sagen continue with
Es ist halt ein bisschen eklig
Cw task 2
Result
Oder war output dass man noch besser lesen kann ich kann auch nicht schreiben output gleich
Task 2 result
So das ist die synchrone variante ich glaube die versteht man prinzipiell ganz gut
Was an der stelle die nicht die synchrone die callback variante
Ich glaube da versteht man relativ gut was von was da ach so ja das könnte tatsächlich auch sein das kann man das machen
Und was ist task 2 dann ist das gleiche macht keinen unterschied oder
Also ich glaube dass das ist die die callback variante die versteht man glaube ich ganz gut oder
Also der macht einen get request
Wenn der get request fertig ist wird das continue mit aufgerufen
Dann holen wir uns das result aus dem get request was unsere response ist
und
response holen wir uns den content raus
Holen wir uns den content raus
Und wollen den als string auslesen allerdings machen wir das auch asynchron mit callback
Weil es kann ja durchaus sein
Dass es ein bisschen länger ist und ein bisschen länger dauert oder vielleicht noch zusätzlich
Sachen geladen werden gerade nachgeladen werden was auch immer das heißt wenn das fertig ist
Dann sagen wir okay continue with holen wir uns das result und geben es aus ich glaube dark wäre das geschrieben
Dark side dark side hd also ich glaube in der callback schreibweise versteht man das eigentlich ganz gut was passiert
Das ist immer wenn fertig dann macht weiter und wenn fertig dann macht weiter ja so
Und im prinzip ist die ganze s und wait geschehen in dem fall nicht die in dem fall ist es ja
Brauchst du das s und keyboard nicht sondern nur wait weil das selbst mit s und implementiert ist
wait macht im prinzip das
Hier hast du ganz viele callbacks und stelle dir mal vor du machst jetzt hier noch drei weitere asynchrone sachen drinne
Dann hast du hier ein rückungstiefe bis zum mond
Eine sache ist in beiden beiden gleich egal ob du das mit wait machst oder mit continue with also in dem fall
Irgendwann irgendwann hängt das ja also wir sind uns jetzt ja einig wenn ich das hier ausführe ja wenn ich hier unten 123 schreibe
Dann wird das hier schon ausgeführt wofür das hier fertig ist
Weil hier das blockt ja nicht
Und damit das nicht blockt
Muss im hintergrund ja irgendwas passieren also das kann es also ich muss das anders erklären wenn das hier synchron wäre
Dann würde jetzt wir machen das mal so hier console readline
Du wirst jetzt feststellen
Der wird als erstes ausgeben 1 2 3 hast du es gesehen da gibt als erstes 1 2 3 aus und erst danach
Gibt er die response aus ist ja logisch weil was passiert an der stelle an der stelle
Gibt es einen background job der losläuft und den get macht dass das jetzt den get request macht und erst wenn der fertig ist wird
Dann asynchron kontinuier ist kontinuier ist gemacht das heißt hier wird es quasi geqt die arbeit
Und dann geht das program ganz normal linear weiter und dann kommt das printline und dann
Irgendwann ist das fertig und dann geht es weiter mit dem kontinuier das heißt es wird im hintergrund geqt
Das jetzt hier in der http get request läuft also für quasi also eine asynchrone io operation gemacht
In javascript ist es relativ einfach weil da gibt es nur einen thread da musst du dir keine gedanken machen ob das jetzt
Asynchron ist ob das background queues sind ob das
Tasks und threads und was auch immer sind in c-sharp ist das meistens so dass das ein
background in backgrounds threadpool gibt
Und das quasi so eine warteschlange mit ganz vielen threads drinnen die nur warten dass sie was erledigen können für dich im hintergrund
Und da wird das reingeschmissen
Und wenn das fertig ist das program läuft da ganz normal weiter und wenn das fertig ist
Wird dann an der stelle hat continuous und noch mal continuous aufgerufen also ich glaube das versteht man an der stelle ganz gut jetzt ist
halt das ding
Dass das ziemlich eklig aussieht und dass das komplett aus dem ruder läuft mit
Einrückungstiefe wenn ich hier noch mehr solche dinger hättest in javascript sieht das übrigens genau so aus ich bin mir gerade nicht sicher wie das
in javascript ausschaut wenn man es von hand aufruft
Denn ist das glaube ich ja hier so mit javascript wäre das so so
Und erwähnt macht jetzt im prinzip was ähnliches wir kürzen wir kürzen das ganze mal wir geben uns mal wir geben uns mal hiermit
zufrieden okay
Wobei ich mache es einfach rückgängig haben wir es ja wieder
Oh, nee ich kann nicht weiter rückgängig machen das ist hässlich
monkaS
Also haben wir das hier await war response gleich
zack so
Hier wirst du jetzt auch sehen das erste was passiert, äh quatsch nicht das erste was passiert plötzlich
Achso ich geb's ja, ich kack noob alter, ich geb's ja gar nicht aus
Okay da muss man doch mal anwarten, war also hier
response content read as string
Await so und jetzt wird dir vielleicht was auffallen
Tja guck mal da jetzt ist die reihenfolge ja auf einmal so wie wir es dahin geschrieben haben
Ich glaube du erkennst den unterschied also jetzt passiert wirklich zuerst das und dann das
Obwohl das eigentlich asynchron sein soll
Und das ist das was await im endeffekt macht das hier wird ganz normal im background gequeued aber
Weil der await davor steht passiert an der stelle eigentlich so eine art return
Ich würde es dir gerne zeigen, aber ich habe keinen decompiler hier
Ich nenne es mal der whoops
Der pausiert quasi an der stelle bis der asynchrone call fertig ist deswegen heißt das auch await
Ich meine return await wäre vielleicht ein bisschen klarer
Der hört einfach hier nach auf oder der hört quasi an der stelle auf
führt das im hintergrund aus
Und wenn das hier fertig ist dann springt er an der stelle wieder rein und macht das weiter das heißt du kannst du kannst
asynchronen code basteln
Der sich ein bisschen verhält wie synchroner code in dem beispiel ist es jetzt nicht so
Nicht so offensichtlich warum das warum das sinnvoll ist
Wenn du dir jetzt aber vorstellst du hast eine ui anwendung
Und ui anwendung frieren mal ganz gerne ein wenn die für 20 30 sekunden hängen
Dann ist das hier natürlich wieder sinnvoll weil dann hängt eine ui anwendung nicht sondern an der stelle hört er einfach mit dem ausführen
dieser funktion auf
Aber die ui anwendung kann weiterhin nachrichten empfangen von windows und verarbeiten und hängt dadurch nicht das müssen wir jetzt eigentlich mal demonstrieren
Man müsste sich es wahrscheinlich wirklich mal in sharp lab angucken da sieht man es vielleicht ganz gut
Ich glaube da können wir das ganze hier copy paste in dem moment das ist kotten das können wir nicht rein copy pasten
Das da
Gucken wir mal ich hoffe man man sieht das man erkennt das gescheit
Chat ich habe mal eine dumme frage warum muss ich http-client nicht inkluden
Wo kommt der her ist es ein global using das könnte sein
Ist das vielleicht auch gott.net macht mir viel zu viel magic in letzter zeit wartet mal
Nee ist es nicht wo kommt das her
Ist global import nicht nicht hier drinne mittlerweile
Na gut was muss ich was muss ich importieren dafür
Was ist denn system.net
Okay das ist using system
Wo ist wo ist wo ist console drinne
In system console okay okay jetzt haben wir es also das ist jetzt natürlich
das ist jetzt natürlich
Kann man das vielleicht groß machen
Zumindest wird das ganze essen gewählt zeug kann ich oh nee nee oh falscher
Kann man hier nicht
Das essen gewählt zeug macht keine großartige also das ist nichts was direkt in der runtime drinne ist unter der haube wird das umgebaut
Zu das ist jetzt nicht so gut
Hier wird das hier wird dass geköz
But the pick lined get get a cent und hier ist die frage
Weil finde ich falsch
und hier ist die frage
if
der hört hier wirklich auf
an der stelle
if not completed
dann geht der einfach
raus aus der funktion
also der hat
meine main funktion umgebaut
in was immer wieder aufgerufen
werden kann
da musst du dir mal ein video angucken wie das genau
funktioniert aber ich finde hier sieht man es
eigentlich schon ganz gut
das ist ja eindeutig meine main funktion
die umgebaut wurde zu so einer Art
async task state machine
hier passiert
der eigentliche get request
so und dann guckt der danach nach
ist der fertig, es kann ja sein dass der instant fertig ist
wenn der instant fertig ist kann er weitermachen
aber in der regel hängt das
erstmal eine weile, dieser get request
der braucht eine weile, der guckt
ist der fertig, ok nein
der ist höchstwahrscheinlich nicht fertig
und jetzt
queter quasi
den callback
hierfür wieder und dann returnt er
das ist auch der grund warum in UI nicht hängen
bleiben würde
weil die funktion wird hier an der stelle
an dem await wirklich, deswegen sag ich ja
return await wäre ein bisschen klarer
an der stelle
das wird tatsächlich
nicht unterbrochen
also die wird beendet, das ausführen
dieser funktion
und sobald der hier fertig ist
dann wird das wieder
aufgerufen
dann wird wieder move next aufgerufen
und dann ist es allerdings
an der stelle so, num ist dann
ungleich 0, weil das der state
wahrscheinlich dann 1 ist
oder sonst was und dann siehst du
ok, wenn er das nächste mal
in diese funktion rein springt
dann wird nicht mehr das hier ausgeführt
sondern es wird der nächste
schritt ausgeführt, nämlich
http response message
und aus der http response message
holt er sich den String raus
das queute er wieder im Hintergrund, er returnt
aus der Funktion, wenn
das hier fertig ist, das ist quasi so eine Art
callback
wenn der background
job fertig ist, dann springt er wieder
hier rein zu move next
dann ist der state diesmal halt
nicht num und nicht das hier und das hier
sondern der state ist dann
das hier
oder immer hier, get result
und hier wird es dann ausgegeben
also im Prinzip ist das wie die mit den callbacks
nur
dass der sich im Hintergrund
drum kümmert und dafür sorgt
dass es so aussieht als wäre
es synchron vom
eigentlichen Ablauf her
aber im Hintergrund ist es tatsächlich
ein background task
sodass deine UIs nicht
einfrieren, hab ich jetzt
beschissen erklärt, aber
es ist spontan recht
schwierig zu erklären
so weiter mit kotlin
wir müssen jetzt hier mal einen get request machen
jetzt kommt die
nächste Frage
wie passt man jason
in kotlin
kotlin jason parser
how to parse jason in kotlin
stackoverflow beste
kotlins
ne
ich will eigentlich
keine Objekte anlegen dafür
ich weiß gar nicht ob kotlin
unterstützt, wahrscheinlich
aber ich weiß nicht wie man das da macht
die haben bestimmt auch
sowas in der Richtung
composing suspending
functions
ok, das ist hiq
shit, ok, aber komm mal
zu kotlin wieder, wie parse ich
das denn jetzt als jason
j object
hab ich da grad schon gesehen
netscape
javascript, moment
was bin ich denn hier
sehend, ich glaube nicht
dass man das braucht, oder
nee, nee, nee
kotlin
parse, ok, da ist doch
standard library irgendwas eingebaut, oder
how to parse jason
in kotlin
example
jason serialization
vielleicht groß geschrieben, ja
jason, nee, auch nicht
tchatke, ich guck mal was ihr hier schreibt
example
serialization, nee
ich will es nicht serializen
ich will es ja, eigentlich will ich
es noch nicht mal deserializen
ehrlich gesagt
ich will es
eigentlich
nur parsen und dann
auf irgendwie ein, zwei Felder
zugreifen, ich will gar keine extra Klassen oder so
erstellen
kotlin x serialization
serialization
serializable, dataclass
data, nee da muss ich das
jetzt ja nachbauen, das ist jetzt nicht so
sinn und zweck der Sache
jason, decode
from string als data
gibt das nicht sowas wie dynamic
object, oder irgendwas
oder sagen wir mal
java
parse jason
gucken wir wie die das machen
von 2010 ist vielleicht ein bisschen
bisschen
übertrieben
introduction zu jason java
dann
introdukte mich mal
ich bin immer wieder überrascht wie kompliziert
wie kompliziert so Sachen manchmal sind
wenn was
nicht in der standard library drin ist
jason object
ok aber das hab ich doch gar nicht
was
yes
nee
moment
hab ich da, wall
moment was ist der unterschied
zwischen war und wall
aha wall
ist quasi nicht mutable
und war ist
ich
muss sagen ohne scheiß
ich find das gut
die kotlin leute haben sich wirklich was
beigedacht, weil well für value
kann ich irgendwie verstehen, ändert sich
nicht, und war für
variable kann sich ändern
ist doch eigentlich gar nicht doof oder
in rust
muss man glaube ich machen
also in rust macht man glaube ich
let blub
u in 32
gleich 1 oder so
korrigiert mich wenn mein rust nicht so
5 header ist im kopf, aber ich glaube das ist
in rust, muss man das so machen
und wenn man das mutable haben will
muss man das glaube ich in rust sogar so machen
oder
oder anstatt let mut
nee
so
dann finde ich das hier
sogar ansprechender ehrlich gesagt
so aber
wie parse ich denn jetzt
fucking jason, so kompliziert kann das doch nicht sein
und was soll
das überhaupt sein
ja das interessiert mich, parse jason without
dataclass
ok das ist ganz gut
kotlin x serialization
ja
das will ich haben, ok
jason
parse to jason element
ok top
jason
parse to jason element, response
body
die preisfrage ist nur
woher bekomme ich diese lab
jetzt, weil
ja dabei ist die ja anscheinend
nicht
kotlin x serialization
wieso ist der funktionsname
groß
wahrscheinlich weil das irgendein objekt ist oder
und die schreibt man halt so
wie http klein und halt mit groß
gibt es denn package
ja da bin ich gerade am überlegen
wie geht das
cradle
hier is a small example
ich hätte jetzt gedacht das ist sowas wie standard library
aber nee anscheinend nicht
ach mein projekt ist im falschen
format oder wie
hä
what
no god
ist jetzt nicht euer ernst oder
das kann
kein package manager
ok das gefällt mir schon mal nicht
rechtsklick auf dein
projekt und dann framework hinzufügen
äh wo
oder ist das
was ist überhaupt mein projekt, das hier
ja ne
ähm module setting
libraries
nee
nee nee das ist irgendwas anderes
da gehts jetzt schon los
was ist denn
in source, gute frage
kotlin
zeug
nee mein source code ist in source
würd sagen das hier
ist mein program
so
package manager, structure
nee wie geht das hier
bookmarks
find end, end point
nee, services
build, terminal
es gibt kein, das hat doch
ein package manager
java hat doch sowas wie ein package manager
hab ich das falsche
vielleicht hab ich auch das falsche
projekt erstellt
lass mal kurz gucken
new, project
ah ich hab build system
intelliJ genannt, ich muss build system cradle
nehmen wahrscheinlich
oder maven oder
wo immer
aber das kann man doch bestimmt
konverten
das kann man doch bestimmt konvertieren hier mein
ich seh aber
nix dafür, ja da sieht man halt
dass ich keine ahnung von java zeug hab ne
gut wir machen das anders
wir copypasten uns das einfach
ich mein easy und sagen
jetzt hier zack
was, package manager
äh
vielleicht konvert
äh, ich leg das
jetzt einfach neu an
new, project
der real
java champ
und jetzt wollen wir kotlin haben
wir wollen das da haben
ach guck mal der wählt sogar
ihr sagt cradle ist für
die cooleren leute oder wie
unsupported module
jdk cradle supports
jdk
no
das ist zu neu
was ich hab
maven
this window
so und jetzt
hab ich package manager zeug
oh, wow
ist ja gut
äh
was hat der jetzt für schmerzen das ging doch eben noch
hä, das geht doch auch
hä
ich benutze das irgendwie falsch
und wie kriege ich jetzt hier
package manager mäßig
add maven dependency
aha
und nach was muss ich jetzt tun
kotlin x serialization
hä
ok, ich hab keine ahnung wie das funktioniert
ja, is shipped with a
kotlin compiler distribution
ja
ja, ja schön
oh
machen wir jetzt nochmal das andere auf
recent projects java champ this window
guck der funktioniert, da hast du gar keine schmerzen mit
also was muss ich
sagen
auf der einen seite schreiben die hier nur irgendwas von
vielleicht, vielleicht, vielleicht hier so
create a project
ja aber das
kann ich ja nicht verwenden
da bin ich, da bin ich zu pp-ger
für, für
ach hier ist doch ein setup guide drin
ok
was zum
what
ok dann öffnen wir das andere, den real java champ
der aus irgendwelchen gründen mit exakt
dem gleichen source code hier als rot angezeigt
wird, ok
nice
warum
wo ist das problem
ach set language version
steht das hier, steht das vielleicht hier drin
soll ich jetzt ernsthaft
xml bearbeiten um pakete installieren
zu können
monkaW
ich glaubs ja jetzt nicht
project settings
tja, wenn ich die finden würde
so, wo steht hier
die language version jetzt
hier
ne
wo hat er denn diese language version
jetzt umgestellt
boah da hab ich keinen bock drauf man
ich will kein xml bearbeiten
ich will einen ordentlichen package manager
guck mal, ich mein
man kann sich jetzt drüber streiten
nougat ist bestimmt nicht der geilste
package manager auf der welt, aber hier kann ich zum
beispiel einfach suchen nach
jason oder so
und was installieren und dann wird es automatisch
hinzugefügt und gut ist, was ist das für ein kack
cargo ist auch nice
ja, wie kann ich denn
jetzt überhaupt was hinzufügen
ich hab jetzt schon gelernt, ich kann jetzt hier hingehen und sagen
add maven dependency
ja das ist ja schön und gut
aber
ich check das net, was muss ich
jetzt machen, hier das da
das da
das gibt's nicht
ne artefact gibt's
auch nicht
ach moment
warum findet er das nicht, wenn ich hier nach suche
ach doch
der ist einfach nur, ich bin einfach nur zu langsam
ja aber das ist doch was anderes
jetzt, das ist doch nicht das was ich
haben will
ah, das was exakt
guck mal
das was exakt matcht, steht weiter unten
das macht jetzt
gerade keine pluspunkte bei mir
kann man das quoten oder so
plus davor
das geht mir auf den sack
da hab ich echt kein nerv drauf
warum eigentlich quoten, weil ich mir mal angucken wollte
wo ist es denn hier
serialization
heißt der krempel doch
ach hier artefakt id
ja
serialization
jason
dann, nein jetbrains
da muss er auch gucken, dass
er echt das richtige erwischt, ok add
hat das jetzt funktioniert
ja nice
aber oh
reload maven
und geht das jetzt auf
magische art und weise
ah
boah ist das eklig man
aber
ich mein, wenn man es weiß
ich glaube man kommt mit klar
ich mein
nugget ist nicht so viel anders
aber schöner integriert, guck mal
mal angenommen
da sag ich hier nugget
und da installieren wir jetzt
newton soft
jason zum beispiel
third party jason
so und da klick ich hier auf das plus
hinzufügen install
und dann ist es da und dann kann ich hier sagen
j object bla bla bla
so, das funktioniert
aber unter der haube, also es ist halt einfach
schön integriert in die ide
unter der haube ist das tatsächlich ähnlich
wie in java gelöst, wenn ich mir das jetzt so überlege
weil
das wird auch hier als dependency
in so einer xml datei geschrieben
nur dass ich da normalerweise nie reingucken muss
und es einfach funktioniert
also
da gefällt mir ja wirklich alles an
da gefällt mir ja sogar npm besser
npm oder ruby gems
gut zumindest
wir haben es hinbekommen
wir haben das jetzt als jason element gepasst
da ist es doch
nice
kann man jetzt hiermit weiter
kann man jetzt hier so auf elemente zugreifen
nein natürlich nicht
das wäre jetzt ja auch zu einfach wenn das
funktioniert
und was
und dann jason object
und da kann man jetzt
ah da kann man jetzt drauf zugreifen
also heißt es im prinzip
wenn ich sowas wie current condition
da rausholen will, dann geht das
ok gut
current condition pressure
temperature in Celsius
ok
das heißt jetzt will ich sowas hier haben
temp c
wie das
funktioniert nicht
ich muss jetzt nicht ernsthaft
nochmal jason object machen oder
äh
jetzt habe ich das jetzt aber kaputt
warum ist es jetzt kaputt
only safe
or non null
assert calls
are allowed on a nullable
receive
kann print line kein null ausgeben
oder was
dann verstehe ich es ehrlich gesagt
gar nicht
du hast ein array
du hast recht
ich habe ein array
aber das ist richtig
aber das weiß das ding ja nicht
an der stelle
der weiß ja nicht wie die struktur aussieht
also es würde
ja aber zu
kann es daran ja nicht liegen
ok ich sag
explizit
scheiß auf null
ok gut
das muss jetzt crashen wahrscheinlich
weil es das nicht gibt
ja
is not
is not a jason object
ja ok dann ist richtig
es ist ein jason array
und dann den
index hoffen wir mal dass das jetzt funktioniert
jawoll
und da drin kann ich jetzt wieder
sagen jason das ist ja maximal
eklig
kann ich nicht
temp
c so machen
vielleicht so
so
och man
hä
und da darf ich das wieder machen
das könnte
doch genauso gut
ne das könnte nicht sein weil ich explizit sage
gib mir den nullten index
und es würde vorher schon crashen das ist auf jeden fall garantiert
nicht null
aber was macht
denn dann
punkt
und wenn es das nicht gibt passiert was
dann crashed es
mit ner null pointer exception
ok mit ner ziemlich miesen
exception wo keiner weiß was sache ist
ich mein wie soll ich von der
exception darauf kommen dass ich hier ein falsches
jason eingegeben hab
also ganz ehrlich
ich
weiß immer wieder die standard.net library
und das ökosystem zu schätzen
da funktioniert vieles einfach so wie man es denkt
insgesamt finde ich
ist kotlin wirklich gut durchdacht
das was wir bis jetzt ausprobiert haben
das dürften wahrscheinlich eher irgendwelche java
eigenheiten über plyapsel sein
ich sag dass es nicht null ist
ja ich will das gar nicht sagen
ich will das gar nicht sagen
ich hätte
hiermit auch kein problem aber das darf ich ja
nicht also es wäre durchaus
ok wenn output null werden kann
und er sagt ja sogar
auch output kann theoretisch null sein
so
an der stelle hier dann natürlich nicht mehr
dann crashed es
das ist trotzdem nicht verkehrt jetzt haben wir die aktuelle
temperatur da haben wir schon mal
ein unserer sachen
jetzt ist die frage wie würde ich beispielsweise
machen wir mal eine klasse
klasse
klasse nennen wir es mal irgendwie
oder so
ok das geht
jetzt wird
spannend
kopieren wir das mal kurz
so
public
ich tue jetzt einfach
einfach mal so als wüsste ich was ich mache
current
mach wahrscheinlich get
temp
string
ok so geht das schon mal
class kotlin
dann müssen wir uns das in der doku mal
angucken
constructor person
ich hab kein constructor
init
nee
nee ich will ne ganz normale methode bauen
functions
muss man ok
es geht an fun
fun
und dann den return type
doppelpunkt
string
schon besser
ist das kein string
nee das ist
ein jason element
nee
da brauche ich jetzt return
string
ok
wie würden
properties funktionieren
achso
nee das ist schon ok
also get current temp
das heißt wir würden hier sowas machen
war oder hier
output gleich
hier nochmal kurz zurück
classes
instance
create instances
of classes
ach einfach so ohne new oder irgendwie sowas
davor einfach groß schreiben
ok
also war output
weather forecast
so
und können wir gleich get current temp machen
wobei
ich muss mal kurz gucken ob die
intellij den namen vorschlagen könnte dafür
nee
aber das ist ja doof
ok get current temp output 23
zack
nice
das ist doch naming convention oder
klein
ok
das ist tatsächlich auch wenn es hier
function heißt
rename
warum sollte ich das rename
was hat er für schmerzen
function name should start with lowercase
achso
aber ich kann es doch bestimmt refactoren
lassen
jetzt hat es überall unbenannt
und es funktioniert auch immer noch
ja ok gut
alles klar so haben wir schon die erste
klasse erstellt
theoretisch können wir das natürlich noch
ein bisschen besser machen und zwar
wir machen ein
konstruktor
der
initialisiert
das ganze allerdings zu einer
create
create property
macht
ach das geht auch so
direkt ok
nicht schlecht
ja ist ok
kann ich mit leben
falls wir noch mehr Sachen
damit abfragen
wollen ist das wahrscheinlich gar nicht so blöd
ja
ok ja why not
gut
so und jetzt kommt die eigentliche Sache
wie machen wir ordentliches
command line parsing mit
kotlin
also http requests und so weiß ich
aber was gibt es
ok kotlin
cli parser
kotlin
xcli ah das ist auch wieder sowas
offizielles
pure kotlin implementation with generic cli parser
i
wieder so
komische dinger
ok das sieht abfuck kompliziert aus
aber es
generiert hilfe texten
automatisch
wir brauchen erstmal
ach nee haben wir schon
ok parser
arc parser
dann probieren wir das nochmal
add maven dependency
und unsere
dependency ist kotlin
xcli jvm
nee
nice
es doch
ok ich
lerne langsam java package manager
und jetzt
muss ich sagen maven
reload
und dann
ach leute so schlimm ist das doch gar
nicht mit dem package manager
das geht doch sogar halbwegs
wenn man sich daran gewöhnt hat
da habe ich schon schlimmeres gesehen
zb c++ header files
ok proc name ist natürlich der
real java champ
meckert er jetzt schon
gleich wenn ich das hier ausführe? nee
intelligent integriert das ganz gut
ja finde ich auch
ok und wie funzt das jetzt
parser parse input
option option option
parser parse arcs
das ist das was ich machen will
es gibt zwar keine arcs zu parsen
bisher aber das macht ja nix
haben wir hier mal
einen return drunter
ja im vergleich zu c++ geht das wirklich noch klar
so
jetzt ist natürlich die preisfrage
wie kriege ich das gestartet mit
hier
run with parameters
das ist halt dumm
deswegen würde ich es halt gerne über cli direkt starten
program arguments
minus minus blub
oder sag mal so
minus minus temp
local
es ist jetzt nicht als würde ich wirklich was
sinnvolles machen damit
so
parse
ach guck mal jetzt sagt er mir auch
anon option minus minus local
da funktioniert schon mal prinzipiell
der
parser champ
jetzt kann ich eine neue option
hinzufügen
die minus minus local heisst
weil
input by parser option
arc type string import
required
single nullable option required
alles klar
input by
by
ok die syntax verwirrt mich jetzt
input by
ist das sowas wie ein using
so ein bisschen
what does by keyword mean
you can understand by
as provided by
ja ach
aber warum nicht so
moment
ist das etwa das gleiche
oder ist das was anderes
dann check ich es nicht so
ganz
dann check ich es nicht so ganz
nun gut wir nehmen das einfach mal zur
kenntnis
short name minus l
aber wo kann ich
moment
wo kann ich denn sagen long
wenn ich nicht short name haben will
sondern tatsächlich
ach full name
hier
local
jetzt sollte er es ja eigentlich checken
no value for local
ok
da muss ich ihm jetzt noch sagen
dass der arc type
bool ist
vermutlich
dass er nicht eine option
haben will
ja nice
ok
bin mir nicht so ganz sicher ob das alles
so
eifertig ist wie ich das mache
formatieren wir mal
neu
reformat
so jetzt haben wir den ganzen
gepasst
und jetzt kann ich gucken
letztendlich will ich ja nichts sinnvolles machen
ich will es ja einfach nur mal ausprobieren
aber da machen wir den ganzen
mit den Listen mal weg
das brauchen wir nicht
local
option
so dann geben wir das für frankfurt
an
klammern drum herum
ne
was ist zeile verschieben in intellij
standardmäßig
so jetzt sollte
wieder die gleiche ausgabe kommen wie eben
ja 26 26 grad hier ok
nice
moin
wie gehts
sauber
aber es ist nicht so schlecht
bis jetzt überzeugts mich
also was geht ist es
sehr gut
warum
quote der überhaupt
die sonst
hier das soll der gar nicht
machen
auf dem
freeze
blanch
das blau
warum kommt
Wo kommen die Quotes her?
Muss ich vielleicht nochmal sagen,
JSON Object to String?
Das ist dann, dass es weg ist?
Naja, du bist null.
Es ist auch kein JSON Object,
sondern JSON Value.
JSON Primitive.
Ne.
Okay, aus irgendwelchen Gründen ist da der Meinung,
dass in dem Response
weiter gequotet sein muss.
Meinst du, es steht einfach so im JSON drin?
Wollen wir mal.
Bam. Ups.
Bam.
Grab minus I.
Temp.
Temp C.
Nö, steht's nicht drin.
Das ist ganz normal, dass JSON,
wenn das gepasst wird als String,
dann ist das der Value.
Und die Quotes sind vom...
Ja, von der Syntax.
Also eigentlich müsste
nur 26 drin stehen.
Ach, muss man sagen,
S-String?
Ist das überhaupt ein Unterschied?
Das wird kein Int.
Cannot be cast.
Ja. Nope.
Genau.
Wenn's ein Int wäre, könnte in JSON auch
ohne Quotes stehen.
Aber ist es nicht. Aber trotzdem ist es falsch.
Das ist nicht das, was ich haben will.
Ich will den Wert haben
als String 26
ohne die Quotes. Die Quotes gehören da auf jeden Fall
nicht dabei. Ich vermute mal,
dass toString eine...
Ja, wie soll man sagen? Eine...
Kommandla... Also eine lockbare
Repräsentation davon
sein soll. Und nicht
den Wert. Das heißt, ich brauche jetzt
eigentlich den Value. Gibt es hier Value oder
sowas?
Was ich bauen will? Nichts. Großartig.
Ich will einfach nur ein bisschen rumprobieren.
Hm.
Long is String?
Content. Das will ich vielleicht
haben. Das könnte
sein. Aha!
Sehr schön.
So muss man das machen.
Da sind auch keine Quotes dabei. Siehste?
Mal kurz drüber nachgedacht.
Easy.
So, if local?
Ja gut. Also, das mit dem... Ich muss sagen,
der Commandline-Parser, der macht so schon mal
gar keinen so üblen Eindruck.
Ich hab ne Idee.
Wir sind blöd.
Wir sagen hier nicht isBool, sondern wir sagen
isString.
Und...
Ja. Genau, so machen wir das.
Und wenn
ungleich null...
Also ich geh mal davon aus...
isAlwaysTrue?
Wie ist
alwaysTrue?
Ach, ich sag ja required da hinten.
Ist ja gar nicht required.
Ja. Genau.
Also, wenn localOption
gesetzt ist, dann
will ich das
übergeben als
Ort. Da können wir nämlich aber gleich gucken,
wie man Parameter
übergibt. Jetzt will
ich currentTemperature haben für...
Theoretisch ist das
sogar im Constructor besser aufgehoben.
Constructor
für...
Moment,
das ging doch anders. Das ging doch hier oben schon
irgendwie drin.
String. Ja, genau.
Also quasi
Location.
Und jetzt
machen wir hier
DollarLocation. Ne, so funktioniert das nicht.
Hm.
Was? Wall?
Ach ja.
Übrigens, das wollen die in der nächsten C-Sharp
Version auch einführen. So was ähnliches wie
das hier. Aber okay.
Besser wäre
ein was? Required?
Ah ne, ein
was? Ein Default
Pulse.
Ne, ein Default
0, oder?
Ne.
Das ist doch ein String jetzt.
Ich will das doch nicht bool machen.
Ich will, dass man
Parameter übergeben kann. Ne, das erscheint
mir so schon...
Was hat er jetzt für Schmerzen?
Ah! Kann ich jetzt
sowas hier machen?
Hm.
Und wie war das? So?
Ah, guck mal, ich hab was
gelernt. Null. Also, wenn das
Null ist, dann
soll das auf
was weiß ich
Berlin
oder so gehen. Okay.
Es muss ja keinen großen Sinn ergeben,
was wir hier bauen.
Ach so, ja. Hä?
Ach so, ja.
Ach so, ja. Ich hab's ja angegeben.
Okay, Input File hier.
Location. Kann man
sagen Default?
Irgendwie so?
Oder Default Frankfurt?
Ja, Berlin ist so ein Drecksloch.
Da will man
nicht als Default haben.
Okay, so geht das auch.
So, jetzt hab ich natürlich Location angegeben.
Was ja keinen Sinn macht.
Also, gehen wir mal Location an.
Local. Tja.
Äh.
Berlin. So.
Zack.
Und jetzt kriegen wir
Temperaturen in Berlin sind
Post Champ.
Äh. Wurde ich grad
gerate limited?
Okay, das sind 21.
Alles klar. Nice.
Gut, jetzt wissen wir schon mal
Bescheid, wie das funktioniert.
Und jetzt kommt die große Preisfrage.
Was passiert, wenn ich
die alle wieder rausschmeiße?
26.
Nice. Okay. Dann setzt er einfach
immer Frankfurt. So. Und jetzt
der letzte Punkt
und einer der wichtigsten Punkte.
Wie mach ich da eine gescheite
Command Line Application raus?
Da hab ich am Anfang schon mal kurz
geguckt.
Aber wie bilde ich das denn
jetzt, dass ich's normal ausführen kann?
Da fehlt mir nämlich
noch jegliche
Vorstellung von.
Ich mein, ich will das ja nicht
verdokkerisieren müssen oder sowas.
Bild.
Mit dem Maven Icon
rechts.
Jetzt blick ich da durch.
Also Leute, was ich machen
will ist, ich glaube das geht überhaupt nicht.
Ich hätte gern
so ein Binary,
was ich ausführen kann.
Wahrscheinlich ist das zu viel verlangt.
Oder zumindest
ein JAR-File oder sowas.
Was macht der denn hier beim Ausführen?
Rechts Maven sollte ein JAR
machen. Ja, aber ich will auch ein Self-Contain
haben, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja, aber ich check nicht, was ich hier machen
muss, ehrlich gesagt.
Diagramm.
Da hab ich drauf gewartet. Endlich.
Nice.
Was? Lifecycle
Package? Wow.
Huiuiui.
Und wo ist jetzt der Output?
Target.
Aha.
Da ist es.
Der real Java-Champ.
Das heißt, ich kann es jetzt zumindest
schon mal
mit Java
minus JAR
ausführen.
Nee.
Natürlich nicht. Wäre ja auch
viel zu einfach, wenn das direkt funktionieren würde.
Okay, in dem Punkt
ist es einfach echt kompletter Müll.
Keine Ahnung, wie das
funktionieren soll jetzt.
Was will das überhaupt
von mir?
Wie groß ist die JAR?
5,4 Kilobyte. Da muss auf jeden Fall
eine Runtime für da sein.
Also, Java-Zeug.
Ich hab keinen Plan, wie das funktioniert.
Okay.
Kotlin self-contained
binary. Geht das irgendwie?
Build final native
binaries. Okay.
Jetzt geht's zur Sache, ja.
Multi-Plattform-Development.
Oh nee,
das kriegen wir nicht mehr gebacken.
Getting start. Das ist Kotlin native.
Ja, da scheint was anderes zu sein.
Alter, ich suche nach einem
Fat-JAR oder Shadow-JAR.
Ich hätte gern
so eine komplett self-contained
Anwendung.
Okay, include runtime brauchen wir
noch, aber ehrlich gesagt, ich
hätte auch gerne
ein komplettes self-contained.
Oh nee, da hab ich keinen
Bock drauf.
Das mach ich jetzt nicht.
Das ist, glaube ich, echt eine Wissenschaft für sich.
Das ist, glaube ich,
echt eine Wissenschaft für sich.
Self-contained heißt ja im Endeffekt,
im Java-Umfeld, pack einfach
die JVM komplett mit rein.
Dann ist dein Binary am Ende dann halt irgendwie
50, 60 MB groß.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob Java
schon auch Versuche in Richtung
Ahead-of-Time-Compilation hat.
Gerade bei
.NET 8
hat sich da viel getan, beziehungsweise wird sich
sehr viel tun noch, wenn das
in ein paar Monaten rauskommt.
.NET 8 Release Date.
Ja, im November.
Ja.
Mal gucken, ob Java auch sowas...
Java Ahead-of-Time-Compilation.
IBM.
Ich sehe schon, das ist tatsächlich gar nicht so einfach.
Für Backend,
für serverseitige Backend-Anwendungen
ist das ja überhaupt kein Problem.
Dann würde ich da jetzt irgendein Docker-Image mitbauen,
mit Java-Runtime drin und fertig.
Kann man sowas
nicht mit der GraalVM machen?
Weiß ich nicht, sagt mir nix.
Was ist denn die
GraalVM?
Compiles your Java
Ahead-of-Time.
Okay. Und wie kann man das
mit Kotlin verwenden?
Okay. Okay, jetzt.
Build a native image of a Java
and Kotlin application.
Aber dazu brauche ich erstmal nicht...
Boah, das ist wieder
hyperkompliziert.
Gu install native
image.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Und wie kompi...
Execute.build
Ne, ne, ne.
Das mache ich heute nicht. Das halte ich heute
geistig nicht aus.
Was ich ein bisschen schade finde, ist, dass das nicht funktioniert.
Ich weiß nicht, warum.
Du bist auf dem falschen Pfad.
Okay.
Na dann.
Wo ist der richtige Pfad?
Ne, aber das machen wir heute nicht mehr.
Das ist mir zu anstrengend.
Da kann ich mich jetzt nicht mit beschäftigen.
Vielleicht beschäftige ich mich da mal noch ein bisschen.
Die Manifest-Datei fehlt.
Mag sein,
aber irgendwie sagt nichts
darüber Bescheid, dass ich eine Manifest-Datei
brauche.
Ach, keine Main.
Was ist denn das Maven-Manifest?
Das hier, oder wie?
Pom.
Ist das das Maven-Manifest?
Pom.xml?
Ich weiß wirklich nicht, wo ich was machen muss.
Ich habe davon absolut keinen Plan.
Kann das hier vielleicht sowas?
Ne.
Und da muss ich eine Main-Methode festlegen.
Das kann man doch bestimmt auch hier drüber machen.
Ne.
Pom.xml Main.
Du müsstest in die
Pom noch schreiben, was ein Manifest
in die JAR soll. Ne, das mache ich jetzt nicht, Leute.
Zack.
Das mache ich jetzt nicht.
Genug Kotlin für heute.
Vielleicht gucken wir uns das nächste Mal tatsächlich
noch weiter an. Ich muss mich erst mal
ein bisschen
noch damit beschäftigen.
Ich würde sagen, als Fazit,
Kotlin als Sprache
echt nice.
Intuitiv.
Man weiß, wie die Sachen gehen, obwohl man sie noch nicht gemacht hat.
Finde ich gut.
Das Java-Ökosystem, boah, ich weiß echt
nicht.
Ja, das, was ich gerade gesagt habe.
Cradle macht einiges einfacher.
Vielleicht gucken wir uns das das nächste Mal an.
So. Chatge.
Wer noch nicht gefollowt hat und wem der Content
gefällt, ich würde mich sehr
freuen, wenn ihr demnächst hier öfters da seid.
Ich muss ein bisschen sehr laut machen, weil ich habe gesehen,
meine Stats waren diese
Woche nicht so gut.
Das geht ja nicht. Cackweight.
Für mehr Stonks.
Ja.
Und ansonsten
würde ich sagen, Chat,
schön,
dass ihr so high IQ seid.
Und wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream.
Macht's gut, bis dann.